GOOD MORNING.
SO.
WELCOME TO.
THIS MORNING'S ELECTIONS AND
REDISTRICTING COMMITTEE HEARING
BEFORE BEGIN HAVE A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING AND I'M
ANNOUNCEMENTS TO MAKE.
SINCE OUR LAST COMMITTEE HERE
WE'VE HAD A CHANGE IN THE
COMMITTEES MEMBERSHIP.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARC STEINORTH
HIS WRISTS IS REPLACING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JIM PATTERSON ON THE
COMMITTEE.
I WILL LOOK FOR THE WELCOMING
HIM WHEN HE WHEN HE GETS A
CHANCE.
WE WANT TO THANK YOU ARE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER PATTERSON FOR
SERVICE ON THE COMMITTEE. AND
SECOND I HAVE A LETTER FROM THE
SPEAKER APPOINTING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER KEVIN MCCARTY TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER EVAN LOW. ON THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE PURPOSE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. ARE ONLY.
IT AND THE THIRD ITEM THE THIRD
ISSUE THE THIRD UPDATE THIS ITEM
NUMBER ONE ON THE AGENDA. AB
TWENTY FIFTY ONE BY SOME MEMBER
CHOI HAS BEEN PULLED FROM
TODAY'S COMMITTEE HEARING BY THE
AUTHOR SO WILL NOT BE HEARD
TODAY AND FINALLY HAVE A LETTER
FROM ASSEMBLYMEMBER OVER
OBERNOLTE. REQUESTING PERMISSION
TO HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
PRESENT AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FIVE ON HIS BEHALF AT TODAY'S
HEARING. ASSEMBLY MEMBER HARPER
WILL TAKE UP THAT BILL AFTER YOU
PRESENT ON YOUR AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY LATER AND HEARING ABOUT
FOR YOU. GREATS.
AND WE HAVE A QUORUM SO MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
BERMAN HERE BERMAN HERE HARPER.
HARPER HERE CALDERON. CALDERON
HERE.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
WEBER. WEBER HERE WE HAVE A
QUORUM.
SO WHEN WE SHOW THE CONSENT
CALENDAR WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON THE
CAN CONSENT CALENDAR TODAY ITEM
NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY NINETY
FIVE BY SOME NUMBER QUIRK SILVA.
DOES ANY MEMBER WISH TO REMOVE
AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEC THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE HAVE
A MOTION AND A SECOND AMOUNTS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSING RE
REFER TO PREPARATIONS RECOMMEND
CONSENT BERMAN.
I BERMAN AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH WEBER AYE WEBER AYE.
GREAT SO THAT'S OUT AND WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND SO LET'S MOVE ON THAT FIRST
WE HAVE.
.
MR LEVINE WITH A. B..
TWO ZERO FIVE FIVE.
MICHELIN.
GOOD MORNING SIR MORNING.
READY WHEN YOU ARE.
THANK YOU.
MOON.
SO MISTER CHAIRMAN FIRST TODAY I
PRESENT AB TWENTY FIFTY FIVE
WHICH WILL PROHIBIT LOBBYISTS
FROM ENGAGING IN SEXUAL
HARASSMENT UNDER THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR. I DON'T THINK THE
COMMITTEE FIRST OF ALL FOR ALL
THE WORK GETS DONE I APPRECIATE
THE AMENDMENTS THAT THEY
RECOMMENDED AND I AM HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THEM TODAY.
THE LEGISLATION IS NEEDED TO
PROTECT PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL COMMUNITY FROM
HARASSMENT AND HOLD.
TRADERS ACCOUNTABLE
SCOPE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
EXPANDS BEYOND THE LEGISLATURE
AND WE HAVE A DUTY PROTECT. THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY.
WE LEARN IN OCTOBER HOW WOMEN
AND MEN HAVE SPOKEN UP. A
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE A COUPLE
COMMUNITY ABOUT THE CULTURE OF
ENABLING HARASSMENT AND ASSAULT
AND IT IS A TIME TO ENSURE THAT
ALL MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY ARE
PROTECTED. AYE ASPIRIN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER LEVINE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING.
WHERE THEY?
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY
NAME'S KRISTY BAUM I'M HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE INSTITUTE OF
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL
ADVOCATE.
WE OUR OF VOLUNTARY NONPARTISAN
ORGANIZATION REPRESENTING
PROFESSIONAL LOBBYISTS IN
CALIFORNIA.
A WE HAD EXTENSIVE CONVERSATIONS
WITH OUR BOARD ABOUT THIS ISSUE.
NO WAY PRECEDING THE
INTRODUCTION OF THIS BILL.
LAST FALL AS THIS.
IF YOU CAME TO LIGHT I ACTUALLY
PERSONALLY WAS A SIGNER.
ON THE LETTER WE SAID ENOUGH.
A I EMBRACE
THE SPIRIT.
OR AT LEAST MY OF PRESUME SPIRIT
OF THE AUTHOR'S INTENT.
TO BE RESPONSIVE
TO THE VICTIMS OF WHAT HAS GONE
ON IN THIS CAPITOL BUILDING IN
THIS COMMUNITY.
A UNFORTUNATELY THE AJ WHILE
THAT HAS BEEN VERY PROACTIVE.
IN A MEETING WITH ITS MEMBERS
HOLDING. A WE ISSUE A PRESS
RELEASE VERY EARLY ON IN OCTOBER
SUGGESTING THAT THIS IS THE
OBLIGATION RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
ENTIRE COMMUNITY. A TO RESPOND
APPROPRIATELY TO WHAT'S
HAPPENING.
A WE SPONSORED A DAY OF
RESOURCES A MONTH AND A HALF AGO
INVITING EVERYONE IN THE
COMMUNITY TO COME LISTEN TO
ATTORNEYS.
TO UNDERSTAND VICTIMS RIGHTS TO
LISTEN TO HUMAN RESOURCES
DIRECTOR IS TO UNDERSTAND WHAT
EMPLOYER OBLIGATIONS ARE AS MANY
OF MY MEMBERS. EMPLOY.
A.
SMITH STAFF OTHER LOBBYIST THAT
CETERA.
A IT'S IT'S INCUMBENT UPON ALL
OF US TO UNDERSTAND. WHAT THE
STRUCTURE IS NOW?
AND WHAT WE ARE SUBJECT TO AND
HOW TO RESPOND AND MAKE SURE
THAT WE AND OUR OWN FIRMS.
PRESENT A SAFE WORKPLACE BUT
ALSO. A AS WE EXTEND OURSELVES
OUTSIDE OF OUR BUSINESSES AND
INTO THE CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
TO PROMOTE A SAFE WORK WORKPLACE
AND WE ARE UNWAVERING IN THAT
COMMITMENT.
UNFORTUNATELY WE FEEL THAT THIS
BILL IS A LITTLE PUNITIVE. A
LITTLE TARGETED.
A TWO ONE ONE CATEGORY OF
PARTICIPANTS IN THIS COMMUNITY.
AND MAYBE THAT FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION WHICH THE
A.
ANALYSIS
CLEARLY POINTS OUT MIGHT NOT BE
THE APPROPRIATE BODY TO
ADJUDICATE ALLEGATIONS
ALLEGATIONS SUCH AS THIS.
AND AS YOU KNOW WE ARE JUST
PROFESSIONALS EXERCISING WHAT IS
A CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT.
OF FREE SPEECH AND TO ADDRESS
THE ELECTED'S
THE REDRESS OUR GOVERNMENT ABOUT
CONCERNS.
SO SUGGESTING THAT SOMEHOW WE
CAN BE BANNED FROM EXERCISING.
THIS.
A.
CONSTITUTIONAL GIVEN RIGHT.
BUT IS TROUBLING SO WE.
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THIS.
BILL OF.
MAYBE NOT JUST BE APPENDED WE
ARE OPPOSED TO THE BILL BUT WE
WANT TO WORK AND WE HAVE NOT
BEEN SHY ABOUT EXPRESSING THEIR
INTEREST AND WILLINGNESS AND
AVAILABILITY. TO BE
COLLABORATIVE ON A COMPREHENSIVE
SOLUTION RATHER THAN WHAT FEELS
LIKE.
A TARGET SHOTS SO AND FOR THESE
REASONS WE ARE OPPOSED TO THIS
MEASURE THANKS FOR YOUR TIME.
LIAM IS BAMA.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ALL BRING IT BACK TO
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
BUT HARPER. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR I OF COURSE THE.
THE THE BARE BONES ANALYSIS
THAT I HAVE IS THAT THIS BILL
PROHIBITS LOBBYIST LOBBYING
FIRMS FROM GAUGING HER SEXUAL
HARASSMENT IS DEFINED IN
AUTHORIZES THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION IS TO SPEND
A LOBBYIST FOR THE VIOLATION
THIS RULE. FOR UP TO FOUR YEARS
I I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS CAN BE AMENDMENTS BE
CLARIFIED ON IF THEY.
.
ATTACK THIS SIDE OF THE CENTRAL
ISSUE OR WHAT WHAT WERE THE
AMENDMENTS THAT SO THE
AMENDMENTS ESSENTIALLY IN AND BE
GLAD FOR FOR THE CHARITY EVEN
TALK ABOUT THEM BUT. IT TAKES
AWAY THAT FOUR YEAR REVOCATION
PART OF THE LANGUAGE AND ALLOWS
FOR.
PENALTIES THAT THE WHICH CAME
BODY WOULD DETERMINE UP MUCH AS
THEY DO RIGHT NOW ALREADY FOR
PENALTIES THAT DAY.
DETERMINE.
IN ANY FINDINGS.
SO THERE'S NO THERE'S NO BAN ON
SPEECH.
SUTURE CLARIFY WHICH WHICH IS
THE BODY THAT SO RIGHT NOW IN
THE LANGUAGE IT IS THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
WHICH IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT MUCH LIKE
THIS COMMITTEE IS RESPONSIBLE
FOR THAT AREA OF CODE.
I DO.
UNDERSTAND FROM CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE COMMITTEE AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
FORTHCOMING COMMITTEE AT THE
JUDICIARY THAT THERE MAY BE
OTHER CHANGES TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE ISSUES THAT. THE LOBBYISTS
HAVE ABOUT BEING REGULATED.
IT IS IMPORTANT TO REGULATE
THAT INDUSTRY AND.
AND I'M OPEN MINDED TO IT BUT
I'VE ALSO BEEN OPEN MINDED. TO
THE LOBBYISTS IDEAS THEY HAVE
NOT PUT FORTH AMENDMENTS OF
THEIR OWN.
AND THAT WOULD BE HAPPY TO TO
INCLUDE ANY OTHER THOUGHTFUL
CONSIDERATIONS ON IN AS IN THE
BILL AS IT GOES FORWARD.
MISTER CHAIR BUT IF I COULD NOT
ON.
THE ISSUE THAT I HAVE IN
PARTICULAR ABOUT THE SITE
KNOWLEDGE THE.
THE ISSUE OF SEXUAL HARASSMENT
AND THE NEED TO BE. FIVE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE STEPPED UP IN
TERMS OF BEING ABLE TO TACKLE
THE ISSUE THE CONCERN I HAVE. IS
THE EQUAL PROTECTION ISSUE THAT
ONE PROFESSION IS BEING SINGLED
OUT AND AND ALSO THAT THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES. COMMISSION
MAY NOT BE THE BEST.
DETERMINANT OF A OF THIS KIND
OF AN ISSUE UP BECAUSE.
THERE ARE MANY LICENSED
I PROFESSIONS BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. IN SO WHY SHOULD
THIS
PARTICULAR PROFESSION BE SINGLED
OUT VERSES REALTORS DOCTORS
DENNIS
OR. I'D ENGINEERS OR ANYONE ELSE
WHO MAY HAVE A LICENSED.
SITUATION MAY HAVE A LICENSE
IN JEOPARDY OR SHOULD THE
DEPARTMENT REAL ESTATE BE
REGULATING REALTORS.
I JUST DON'T SEE THAT THE
CONNECTION OR THE NEXUS.
ON THIS ISSUE AND I SO I THINK
THAT A A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
BILL.
THAT TACKLES THE ISSUE ACROSS
THE BOARD AYE IS MORE
APPROPRIATE I THINK.
THEN NOW AND THEN.
TACKLING THIS A BY PUTTING THE
FPP SEE IN CHARGE THIS WHICH I
THINK MAYBE A MISPLACED AGENTS.
MISTER HARPER LOOK FOR TO
CONSIDERING YOUR PROPOSED
LEGISLATION.
THEMES HARBOR ANY ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS HAVE A QUESTION THAT
WEBER.
THE SONG
OKAY SO NO LIGHT. UP TO
ABSENT OF THE IF YOU DIDN'T HAVE
THIS BILL.
.
WHAT WOULD THAT HAPPEN I MEAN I
I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED ABOUT DUE
PROCESS
AND MAKING SURE THAT PEOPLE HAVE
THEIR DAY IN COURT?
AND WHETHER NOT.
WE'VE GOT THIS HERE.
IF THIS DIDN'T EXIST
OF WHAT WOULD BE THE PROCESS
A PERSON OF SAID THEY WERE
BEING.
SEXUALLY HARASSED AND MAY
HAPPEN TO BEEN LOBBYIST
WHAT WOULD BE THE PROCESS FOR
THEM AT THAT TIME AT OCTOBER
THINK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
QUESTION THERE ISN'T ONE.
RIGHT NOW.
THERE'S NOWHERE TO TO GO TO IT
TO MAKE SURE THAT SOME IS HELD
ACCOUNTABLE FOR PERPETRATING.
A CRIME LIKE THIS SORT OF MAKES
ONE FEEL UNCOMFORTABLE IN THE
WORKPLACE I'VE HAD.
.
PEOPLE THAT HAVE WORKED IN THIS
BUILDING FOR YEARS COME TO ME
AND TELL ME STORIES ABOUT HOW
THERE WOULD BE A LOBBYIST WHO
WOULD COME INTO THE OFFICE AND
WOULD MAKE. A YOUNG WOMAN IN
THEIR OFFICE.
CAN
SO NERVOUS SHE WOULD PHYSICALLY
SHAKE EVERY SINGLE TIME THAT HE
CAME IN THERE.
AND THAT CHIEF OF STAFF HAD TO
GO AND CALL THAT LOBBYIST AND
TELL HIM. TO WATCH HIS BEHAVIOR
WHEN HE WAS COMING INTO THE INTO
THE OFFICE.
AND THAT THERE IS NO WHERE TO.
TO YOU KNOW HOW THIS BE RECORDED
ON A RECORD OF THAT PERSON'S
LOBBYING.
I'VE HAD.
YOU BIT THE GENESIS REALLY OF
THIS BILL ITSELF WAS THE LETTER
THAT KICKED OFF
THIS LOOK AT THE CAPITOL CULTURE
AS IT'S BEEN CALLED WHICH WAS
ABOUT LOBBYIST ON LOBBYIST
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
AND THAT THERE WAS REALLY NO
WHERE TO GO.
AND I I THINK THAT IF WE LOOK
AND SEE WHAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS
IN THIS BUILDING SPECIFICALLY.
WE HAVEN'T DONE ENOUGH AND WE
HAVEN'T DONE EVERYTHING YET. ON
BUT WE HAVE TAKEN IT VERY
SERIOUSLY HOW WE CLEAN THIS
PLACE UP AND I SPEAK FROM A
PLACE OF PRIVILEGE I'VE NEVER
EXPERIENCED THIS. MYSELF BUT I
KNOW THAT WE'RE TRYING TO TACKLE
THIS ISSUE.
BUT WHAT WE HAVEN'T DONE IS
ADDRESS THE ISSUE THAT WAS
BROUGHT UP IN THAT ORIGINAL
LETTER A THIS BILL IS TO SAY
EVERYONE IN THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY DESERVES PROTECTION.
NOT JUST A.
MEMBERS AND STAFF IN AND HOW
THAT INTERVIEW THAT INTERACTION
OCCURS IN HERE. THE FACT THAT.
MEMBERS AND STAFF HAVE ALSO HAD
THESE.
INTERACTIONS THE IN INVOLVING
SEXUAL HARASSMENT WITH LOBBYISTS
AND.
IT IN AND WE NEED TO ADDRESS IT
SOMEHOW THIS BILL ISN'T. IN ITS
FINAL FORM THERE'S A LOT MORE
WORK TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT IT
WORKS WE HAVE TO PROTECT
EVERYBODY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS BOB
BUREAU. AND THE TREASURE OF AYE
GA AND I'D.
LIKE TO CLARIFY.
DOCTOR WEBBER'S QUESTION.
DIDN'T MISTER LEVINE'S ANSWER.
CURRENTLY.
ANY MEMBER ANY STAFF MEMBER CAN
FILE A COMPLAINT WITH THE ETHICS
COMMITTEE ANY TO THE ASSEMBLY OF
THE SENATOR THE JOINT ETHICS
COMMITTEE.
MAKE A COMPLAINT CAN BE FILED
WITH THE RULES COMMITTEE.
WE ARE REGULATED BY THE FAIR
POLITICAL PRACTICES COMMISSION
AND AS SUCH WE HAVE TO TAKE.
LOBBYING A ETHICS COURSES EVERY
TWO YEARS WHICH INCLUDE THE SAME
SEXUAL HARASSMENT TRAINING THAT
THE MEMBERS AND THE STAFF TAKE.
SO WE ALREADY ABIDE BY THOSE
RULES DOCTOR WEBER. AND WE ALSO
HAVE TO FACE THE DEATH THINKS
COMMITTEE OF THERE'S A COUPLE
EIGHT FILED A NO COULD THE
INTERNAL RULES BE MODIFIED AS
THE SENATE IN THE ASSEMBLY ARE
WORKING ON ABSOLUTELY TO
STRENGTHEN THOSE. BUT I DON'T
BELIEVE WE AS AN ORGANIZATION
BELIEVE THAT THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT SHOULD BE AMENDED TO
HAND THIS OVER TO REGULATORY
AGENCY THAT IN A SENSE REGULATES
OUR FILINGS AND OR LOBBYING
ACTIVITY.
OKAY I.
.
OUT.
IN I HAVE SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
AYE ARE PROBABLY WILL SUPPORT
THIS TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO SEE
WHAT THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
DOES.
YEAH I I HAVE A.
LIKE THIS I HAVE A REAL CONCERN
IS AB EXPRESSED EVEN WITH ALL
pOCCURRED. THAT SOMETIMES IN OUR
EFFORTS TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
OF WE HAVE A TENDENCY TO RUN
OVER ALL OF THE FOLKS RIGHTS OR.
OR MORE IMPORTANTLY RESTED
RUSTED DECISIONS THAT PROBABLY
IF FOUGHT IF THEY HAD GONE
THROUGH THE NORMAL PROCESS WHICH
SOMETIMES TAKES TIME AND IS
ALWAYS AGITATING BECAUSE IT'S
LONG BUT JUSTICE IS LAW. AND A
AND HAS TIME TAKES TIME THAT
WE WOULD DO THINGS THAT.
.
OF THAT MAKE SENSE INITIALLY
NOTHING EVEN IN THE WHOLE ISSUE
WAS WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING HERE
AT THE CAPITOL THERE AS I LISTEN
TO MEMBERS THERE'S SOME. NOW.
NOT INITIALLY REGRETS BUT
CONCERNS ABOUT THE RUSH TO
JUDGMENT ON OFF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT INDIVIDUALS AND SO.
I KNOW THE DUE PROCESS IS A
PROCESS THAT SOMETIMES PEOPLE
DON'T OR DON'T FEEL COMFORTABLE
AN ENGAGING IN. DON'T FEEL THAT
THAT THAT THEY HAVE THE ABILITY
TO FILE COMPLAINTS EVEN THOUGH
THEY DO. ARE AND IT'S IS A LONG
PROCESS BUT IF IF YOU'RE GOING
TO TALK ABOUT.
IN FAIRNESS TO BOTH SIDES OF THE
THE DISCUSSION.
CLEARLY.
WE HAVE TO HAVE THAT SO I'M A
LITTLE BIT MORE INTO THIS I'M
GONNA SUPPORTED TODAY BECAUSE I
WANTED TO GO TO THE JUDICIARY
AND I WANT TO TALK WITH THE.
THIS YEAR CHAIR AND FIND OUT HOW
WE'RE GOING TO DEAL WITH THIS
AND WHETHER THAT IS GOING TO BE
IN LINE WITH THE OTHER THINGS
THAT WOULD DOING HERE. AT THE
CAPITAL.
US TO MAKE SURE THAT WE DON'T
VIOLATE.
FOLKS RIGHTS AND DON'T TRAMPLE
ON PROCESSES THAT ALREADY EXIST
THAT MAY NEED TO BE
STRENGTHENED.
SO I THANK YOU FOR THAT COHEN
THANKS TO THE AUDIENCE FOR THEIR
COMMENTS. THAT YOU DON'T WEBER.
MAY THIS WILL COME AS A
QUESTIONS.
YOUR CLOTHES.
TO ME ONE SECOND I SEE ANOTHER
MEMBER OF THE COMMITTEE.
SOME ARE MULLIN WOULD YOU LIKE
TO ASK ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
ON MISS PHILIPPINES BILL.
THANKS.
FOR OVER TO CLOSE WELL I'D BE
GRATEFUL FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
SO I COULD CLOSE ON THAT.
I'LL SECOND.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
ARE SEQUESTERED AYE VOTE.
SO THE LEGISLATURE IS
CONSIDERING A NUMBER OF BILLS
THIS YEAR ON THE TOPIC OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT AND UNFORTUNATELY
THIS COMMITTEE.
AS IT'S BEEN EXPRESS THE
FRUSTRATION BY BY COLLEAGUES IS
IN THE DIFFICULT POSITION OF
DEALING WITH ONLY A SMALL
SLIVER.
OF THAT IMPORTANT ISSUE AND.
I. UNDERSTAND THAT THAT
CONCERNS EXPRESSED BY THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL THAT
THEY FEEL LIKE THEY'RE BEING
SINGLED OUT.
AND I THINK THAT'S A VALID
POINT AND AND I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS THAT WERE RAISED BY MY
COLLEAGUES.
ULTIMATELY I THINK THERE'S A
BROAD AGREEMENT THAT THE
RESPONSE TO THE ME TOO MOVEMENT
NEEDS TO BE A COMPREHENSIVE.
AND WE ARE DOING OURSELVES ANY
FAVORS IF WE SIMPLY TARGET A
SMALL SLICE OF THE CAPITAL
COMMUNITY FOR NEW RULES AND
REGULATIONS.
AND I THINK THAT WAS PART OF THE
SENTIMENT BEHIND THE CREATION OF
THE JOINT RULES SUBCOMMITTEE.
ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT PREVENTION.
IN RESPONSE.
THAT WE NEED TO LOOK AT THIS
ISSUE HOLISTICALLY AND TO
DEVELOP COMPREHENSIVE SOLUTIONS
TO CHANGING THE COURTS OR ON
SEXUAL HARASSMENT.
BECAUSE BECAUSE THEY ARE PART OF
THE LARGER CAPITAL COMMUNITY.
ANY SOLUTION TO CHANGING THE
CULTURE ON SEXUAL HARASSMENT
MUST INVOLVE LOBBYISTS.
BUTTON THIS BILL IS VERY MUCH A
WORK IN PROGRESS.
I THINK THERE ARE LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS ABOUT WHETHER THE F.
PPC IS THE PROPER ENTITY TO BE
INVESTIGATING COMPLAINTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT I'D I'D. AND
VERY SKEPTICAL THAT IT IS. A AND
EVEN IF THE F. PPC CAN FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO APPROPRIATELY
INVESTIGATED THOSE COMPLAINTS.
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE PENALTIES
THAT ARE FOUNDIN THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT ARE NECESSARILY THE
RIGHT REMEDIES
FOR THIS TYPE OF MISCONDUCT.
ON THE OTHER HAND BECAUSE THEY
ARE NOT EMPLOYEES OF THE
LEGISLATURE THEIR CHALLENGES
ABOUT HOW TO RESPOND TO
SUBSTANTIATE THE COMPLAINTS OF
SEXUAL HARASSMENT. BY LOBBYISTS.
UNLIKE MEMBERS OF THE
LEGISLATURE WHO CAN BE CENSURED
SUSPENDED OR EXPELLED FROM HIS
CONDUCT.
OR LEGISLATIVE STAFF WHO CAN BE
TERMINATED OR SUSPENDED OR HAVE
OTHER DISCIPLINARY STEPS TAKEN
AGAINST THEM. THE OPTIONS FOR
DISCIPLINARIAN THE OPTIONS FOR
DISCIPLINING LOBBYIST SOON GAYS
AND SEXUAL HARASSMENT ARE LESS
WELL DEFINED.
SO I THINK A DISCUSSION ABOUT
THE APPROPRIATE WAY TO RESPOND
TO SEXUAL HARASSMENT BY
LOBBYISTS IS A WORTHWHILE ONE TO
HAVE AS PART OF THE BROADER
CONVERSATION. ON THIS ISSUE.
SO I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THIS
BILL TODAY SAID THIS ISSUE
REMAINS PART OF THE THAT
CONVERSATION.
AND AS DOCTOR WEBER MENTIONED I
THINK THAT A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
CONVERSATION WILL OCCUR IN THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. WHERE THEY
WILL BE HEARING A LARGE NUMBER
OF BILLS DEALING WITH SEXUAL
HARASSMENT?
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT ARE MOST SQUARELY IN THIS
COMMITTEE'S JURISDICTION. AND I
HOPE THAT REGARDLESS OF WHAT
HAPPENS TO THIS BILL TODAY THE
ISSUE MISCONDUCT BY LOBBYISTS
WILL BE VIEWED IN THE
APPROPRIATE CONTEXT.
BECAUSE I THINK THIS IS A VERY
SMALL BUT IMPORTANT PIECE OF A
VERY LARGE AND COMPLEX PUZZLE.
WITH ALL THAT BEING SAID I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT WITH THE
AMENDMENTS ON THIS BILL
A WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE BERMAN AYE
HARPER.
HARPER NOT VOTING CALDERON.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
SO WE'LL KEEP THAT OPEN FOR.
.
THAT BILLS ON CALL.
AND WILL KEEP.
THEN LEVELS UNCLE THOSE THAT
VIGGO THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
SO NEXT UP WE HAVE.
SOMEONE NUMBER GRAY WITH AB
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE.
WHEN YOU READ MISTER GRAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU I WILL BEGIN.
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE'S
RECOMMENDED AMENDMENTS.
IDENTIFIED ANALYSIS ONE
STRIKING THE LANGUAGE RELATING
TO THE RECEIPT OF A CONTRIBUTION
AS NOTED ON PAGE FOUR OF THE
ANALYSIS.
I AND NUMBERS AND SECONDLY I TO
EXPAND THE BILL TO INCLUDE. THE
RARE INSTANCES IN WHICH THE
ASSEMBLY CONFIRMS GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTEES.
HAS NOTED ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
ANALYSIS IN FRONT OF YOU
MEMBERS.
WITH THOSE AMENDMENTS AB TWENTY
SIX EIGHT NINE WILL PROHIBIT A
POLITICAL APPOINTEE. FROM MAKING
A CONTRIBUTION OR PROVIDING A
GIFT TO A LEGISLATOR OR ANY
COMMITTEE CONTROLLED BY THAT
LEGISLATOR DURING THE PERIOD IN
WHICH THE APPOINTEE IS SEEKING
CONFIRMATION.
UNDER EXISTING LAWS WE ALL KNOW
ALL TO WELL ON THE HEELS OF THE
RECENT FORM SEVEN HUNDRED
DEADLINE. GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS
LEGISLATORS LOBBYISTS LOCAL
PUBLIC OFFICIALS AND OTHER
GROUPS ARE IN IRAQ WITH THE
POLICY MAKING PROGRESS.
ARE SUBJECT TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT.
THE LAW REQUIRES US TO A REPORT
GIFTS CONTRIBUTIONS.
I GIVE TO RECEIVED SHAREHOLDER
INTEREST REAL PROPERTY INTERESTS
AN OUTSIDE APPOINT THE OUTSIDE
EMPLOYMENT AMONG OTHER THINGS.
AS NOTED BY THE F. PPC ITSELF
THE GOAL OF THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT IS TO PREVENT BIASES.
ACTUAL AND APPARENT THAT RESULT
FROM FINANCIAL INTEREST OF
DECISION MAKERS.
HOWEVER POLITICAL APPOINTEES WHO
HAVE NOT YET BEEN CONFIRMED BY
THE LEGISLATURE FACE NO
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS.
AND NO ADDITIONAL SCRUTINY BY
THE F. PPC.
AS A RESULT AN INDIVIDUAL
SEEKING THE CONFIRMATION OF A
CONFIRMATION VOTE OF A SENATOR.
ORRIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR THAT
MATTER IS FREE TO PROVIDE GIFTS
AND OR CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THOSE LEGISLATORS
FOR PERSONAL GAIN.
PROHIBITING SUCH CONTRIBUTION
ACTIVITY IS NOT A NEW IDEA
EXISTING LAW LIMITS
CONTRIBUTIONS TO MEMBERS OF
BOARDS AND COMMISSIONS.
AND APPOINT OFFICIAL MAY NOT
ACCEPT A CONTRIBUTION OF TWO
HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS OR MORE
FROM AN APPLICANT UNTIL THREE
MONTHS AFTER HIS OR HER.
AGENCY'S DECISION ON THE MATTER
IS FINAL.
WE THE STATE LEGISLATURE MUST
HOLD ITSELF TO A HIGHER STANDARD
BY ADDRESSING A SIMILAR PRACTICE
IN THE CONFIRMATION PROCESS
WHICH IS CURRENTLY PERMITTED
UNDER LAW.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
SING NUMBER IMPACT ALWAYS FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
BUT YOU'RE HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JOB.
MEMBER THANK YOU FOR UPBRINGING
THEY SAID THIS ISSUE FORWARD I
THINK IT'S A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSUE. I IN SOME THE BACKGROUND
MATERIAL I THINK.
HELPS CARACTERIZA THE CONCERNS
THAT THAT THAT I AS WELL AS MANY
VOTERS HAVE
I IN TERMS OF CONTRIBUTIONS AND.
THEIR RELATIONSHIP A WITH
APPOINTMENTS.
I. THE ONE OF THE ARTICLES THAT
DAY YOU'VE SUBMITTED FROM THE
LOS ANGELES TIMES DETAILED.
A SITUATION SPECIFIC TO THE
CALIFORNIA TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION I AND A.
AND SOMEONE WHO HAD TO ARRANGE
FOR A CONTRIBUTIONS TO BE MADE.
UP BUT THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS WERE
ALSO MADE TO THE GOVERNOR AS
WELL AND I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU.
AMENDED THIS TO INCLUDE MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE AS WELL AS THE
ASSEMBLY I THE QUESTION I HAVE
IS UP WHY WITH WHERE THEY'RE NOT
INCLUDED AMENDMENTS OR THE
ORIGINAL CRAFT. I INCLUDED IN
THE GOVERNOR.
IS WELL SINCE I OBVIOUSLY THE
APPOINTMENT PROCESS AYE IS
CONTROLLED BY THE LEGISLATURE AS
WELL AS A MORE IMPORTANTLY THE
GOVERNOR.
THEMSELVES.
ME THE THE ANSWER I'LL TAKE THAT
QUESTION AND I THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMENTS.
AS IT RELATES THE GOVERNOR AND.
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENT
PROCESS IT'S MORE OPEN ENDED
I AND WE ARE.
AS A MATTER OF PRACTICAL PURPOSE
DON'T REALLY HAVE A WAY OF
IDENTIFYING A WHO HAS OR HASN'T.
POTENTIALLY BEEN CONSIDERED UP
FOR APPOINTMENT A GIVEN THE.
THE LACK OF INFORMATION I DON'T
SEE A A FEASIBLE WAY IN WHICH TO
INTEGRATE THEM INTO THIS OUR
PARTICULAR.
MEASURE BUT I APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND.
BUT CERTAINLY THE INTENT. BEHIND
THE QUESTION.
YEAH OF MISTER CHAIR IF I COULD
UP BRIEFLY COMMENT IS THAT THE I
AGREE WITH THE.
CONCERNED SIDE OF THE AUTHOR
AND OUT WITH THE INTENT.
BUT THE THE MEASURE WON'T HAVE
MY VOTE TODAY BECAUSE I
SINCERELY BELIEVE THAT THE IF
ORDER TACKLE THIS ISSUE IT
SHOULD BE BOTH THE LEGISLATURE
AS WELL AS THE GOVERNOR THAT'S
COVERED BY.
I THINK MISTER VARMA ECCLES JUST
FOLLOW UP ON THAT VERY MISTER
VICE CHAIR. AND I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT. TO GET OUR ARMS
AROUND THIS FROM THE POINT PRESS
PARTICULARLY GIVEN THE FACT THAT
WE'VE WE'VE CONTINUED TO SEE THE
LEGISLATURE SEED. A MUCH OF ITS
AUTHORITY TO THESE APPOINTED A
POSITIONS.
AND ARE WHILE THIS MAY NOT BE A.
HOLISTIC ENOUGH BUT FOR YOU IT
CERTAINLY TAKES THAT FIRST STEP
IN MAKING THOSE PEOPLE
ACCOUNTABLE SO THAT YOU DON'T
HAVE.
BEEN APPOINTEE OF THE WATER
BORDER THE AIRBORNE OR ANYTHING
ELSE ANA THROWING FUNDRAISERS
FOR THE CURRENT SANDERS VOTING
ON THEIR CONFIRMATION THAT POINT
YET I THINK IT'S A GOOD FIRST
STEP IT. HOLDS THEM ACCOUNTABLE
IN THE BILL A IN THAT WAY HOLDS
THE GOVERNOR'S APPOINTEE PROCESS
ACCOUNTABLE IN THE BILL. I EVEN
IF WE HAVEN'T GOTTEN AROUND.
THE POTENTIAL APPLICANTS.
THE VERY MUCH AND I'M GONNA
QUICKLY GO BACK I TO WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT I THINK WE WE DO
HAVE ONE YES MA'AM. WHOSE
MIRAMONTE ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA.
EXPANSION OF THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT IS CONSISTENT WITH
THE LEAKS POSITIONS ON CAMPAIGN
FINANCE AND MONEY IN POLITICS.
WE ARE SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
SECOND.
AND THE ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AND COLLEAGUES.
ISRAEL TO CLOSE WISH LIKE WE ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
SO THIS BILL WILL HELP PROTECT
AGAINST ANY PUBLIC PERCEPTION
THAT CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTIONS AND
GIVES COULD INFLUENCE THE
LEGISLATURE'S VETTING
CONFIRMATION PROCESS A GOVERNOR
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTEES.
AND I WANT TO COMMEND THE AUTHOR
FOR CRAFTING THIS BILL CAREFULLY
IN AN EFFORT TO PROTECT AGAINST
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGES.
AND FOR WORKING WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON THE AMENDMENTS THAT
ARE OUTLINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
WITH THOSE AND AMENDMENTS AMER
COMMANDING A.
THEN I GO.
THANK YOU THANK YOU MADAM
SECRETARY HE PLEASE HELLO THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE AYE. BERMAN
AYE HARPER VOTING TODAY HARPER
NOT VOTING CALDERON.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
IT'S LEVELS ON CALL THE YOU'RE
MUCH TAKE WHICH CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS.
NEXT UP WE HAVE AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THREE BY SOMEONE NUMBER
SAVANT THIS.
READY WHEN YOU ARE
.
GOOD MORNING COLLEAGUES SEN
MISTER CHAIR APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT ON
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE TODAY. I WOULD LIKE TO
START OFF BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
AS DESCRIBED ON PAGE SIX OF THE
ANALYSIS I WANT TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR. THEIR
ASSISTANCE ON THIS BILL THE
PURPOSE BEHIND ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE IS TO
PROVIDE BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
AND THE CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATIONS WITH MORE TIME TO
IMPLEMENT THE TRANSITION. TO
DISTRICT BASED ELECTIONS THE
ENACTMENT OF ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY AND TWENTY SIXTEEN SET UP
THE CURRENT SYSTEM WHICH GOVERNS
THESE TRENDS ADD TRANSITIONS.
HOWEVER ASSEMBLY BILL THREE
FIFTY BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
CIVIL RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS HAVE
FOUND THAT MORE TIME IS NEEDED
TO IMPLEMENT THESE TRANSITIONS.
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS OFTEN THE MORE
TIME TO DO PUBLIC OUTREACH CIVIL
RIGHTS ORGANIZATIONS OFTEN THE
MORE I TIME TO HELP
UNREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES
ORGANIZED IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO
ADVANCE OTHER INTEREST.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE WOULD HELP ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE BY PROVIDING FOR A
MUTUALLY AGREED TO EXTENSION OF
NINETY DAYS TO IMPLEMENT THE
TRANSITION TO DISTRICT BASED
ELECTIONS. AYE DURING THAT TIME
POTENTIAL PLAINTIFFS WOULD
REMAIN BARRED FROM COMMENCE SEEN
A LITIGATION AGAINST LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS UNDER THESE CB ARE
A.
I JUST AS THEY ARE UNDER THE
EXISTING SYSTEM ODD GIVEN
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY I LIKE
TO NOTE THAT THIS IS A CONSENSUS
BILL SUPPORTED BY THE LEAGUE OF
CITIES AS WELL AS MALL DEATH A
SEATTLE YOU. COMMON CAUSE IN A
SEVEN IN THE AYE AYE ASIAN
ASSEMBLY EXCUSE ME ASIAN
AMERICANS ADVANCING JUSTICE A
COLLEAGUES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT ON THIS BILL
WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
DANE HUTCHINGS. ON BEHALF OF THE
LEAGUE OF CITIES AND NICHOLAS
HIGH DOOR AND WITH THE
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE.
THE.
CHAIR MEMBERS NICOLAS SITE ON
CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE VERY
PROUD SPORT AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE WHICH WILL PROVIDE UNDER
REPRESENTED COMMUNITIES WITH
MORE TIME IN OPPORTUNITIES TO
ENGAGE IN AN INAUGURAL
DISTRICTING PROCESS.
THIS YEAR I WAS DESIGNED TO
ENSURE UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
COMMUNITIES HAVE A FAIR
OPPORTUNITY FOR REPRESENTATION
ON THEIR LOCAL GOVERNING BOARDS.
MOST COMMON SEE VERY REMEDY IS
TO OUR JURISDICTIONS WITHOUT
LARGE ELECTIONS SYSTEMS
TRANSITION BY DISTRICT ELECTIONS
WHERE THERE'S LESS OF A CHANCE
MINORITY VOTE DILUTION.
BECAUSE THIS CHANGES MADE TO
EMPOWER UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES IS VITAL FOR THOSE
COMMUNITIES HAVE A VOICE IN THAT
FIRST DISTRICTING PROCESS.
THE LEGISLATURE IS THE MEMBER
MENTIONED RECENTLY PASSED THE
NUMBER OF A BENEFICIAL
IMPROVEMENTS THIS HE VERY
INCLUDING AB THREE FIFTY BY
SOMEONE MEMBER LAY HOPE. WHICH
SET UP THAT NINETY DAYTIME CARE
FOR TRANSITIONS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WHO WISH TO REMAIN A
WITHIN THE STATUTORY CAP ON
RETURNEES FEES. WE THINK AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE REALLY
BUILDS ON THAT FRAMEWORK.
MOST SIGNIFICANTLY IT ALLOWS A
SEE VERY PERSPECTIVE PLAINTIFF
AND LOCAL JURISDICTION TO
MUTUALLY AGREE TO AN EXTENSION
BY UP TO NINETY DAYS FOR A TOTAL
OF A HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS. TO
COMPLETE THAT DISTRICTING
PROCESS.
THIS PROVIDES FOR MORE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR ENGAGEMENT AND
MOBILIZATION UNDER REPRESENT
COMMUNITIES.
TELL OF USEFUL ENGAGEMENT OF
UNDERREPRESENTED COMMUNITIES IN
THE DISTANT PROCESS OFTEN
REQUIRE IDENTIFYING COMMUNITY
LEADERS GOING ON EDUCATING
PEOPLE IN THE DECISION PROCESS
AND WHITE SO IMPORTANT
REPRESENTATION. AS WELL AS
MOBILIZING THE COMMUNITY TO
ATTEND HEARINGS AND TO TESTIFY.
WE'VE HEARD ON THE GROUND FROM
SO RIGHTS GROUPS AS WELL AS FROM
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS THE CAN BE
DIFFICULT ACCOMPLICES IN ONLY
NINETY DAYS.
WE THINK AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREES TIME EXTENSION WILL
GREATLY HELPED US THE BENEFIT TO
BOTH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
UNDERREPRESENTED CHANGES FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE TAUGHT
VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN RETAIN
HUTCHINS LIQUOR CALIFORNIA
CITIES.
PROPER SUPPORT AB TWENTY ONE
TWENTY THREE TO SIMPLE EXPANSION
HAS BEEN AND AS BEEN DISCUSSED
HAVE ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIFTY
WHICH IS A WEEK SPONSORED
MEASURE. WHICH PROVIDE A SAFE
HARBOR PROVISIONS FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO ENABLE THEM TO
CONVERT DISTRICTS BY ORDINANCE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW CITIES DO FEEL
RUSHED TO ENGAGE STAKEHOLDERS IN
ORDER TO AVOID A VERY COSTLY
LITIGATION IF YOU'RE OUTSIDE OF
THE SAFE HARBOR PROVISIONS.
BUT I AB TWENTY ONE TWENTY
THREE ALLOWS SAID IN ADDITION
NINETY DAYS TO CONVERT TO
DISTRICTS UPON MUTUAL AGREEMENT
WITH THE PERSPECTIVE PLAINTIFF.
I'M ALTHOUGH THE LEAGUE IS BEEN
ON RECORD AS STATING THAT THEY
DON'T BELIEVE THAT DISTRICTS AND
I THE ONE SIZE FITS ALL APPROACH
DISTRICTS SHOULD BE THAT WAY.
THAT IT SHOULD BE.
THE.
THE LEGISLATURE SPOKEN THAT
REALLY IS THE DIRECTION THE
STATE WANTS TO GO AND.
WE DO DO SUPPORT MORE TIME
WITHIN THE CONFINES OF AB THREE
FIFTY WE THINK THAT BILL THIS
BILL WILL HELP LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
REACH OUT TO STAKEHOLDERS.
I HAVE A CHIU REPRESENTATIVE
DEMOCRACY AND ENSURE THAT I'M WE
HAVE DISTRICTS DONE THE RIGHT
WAY. I'M WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT I'M
WORKING WITH AT THE CIVIL RIGHTS
GROUP THE AUTHOR IN THE OPEN
GOVERNMENT GROUPS AND THAT WE
CAN TRY TO FIND OTHER WAYS TO
ENSURE MORE OPTIONS ARE
AVAILABLE TO SATISFY VOTING
RIGHTS ACT LAWSUITS BUT. FOR
TODAY'S PURPOSES WERE CERTAINLY.
A PROUD TO SUPPORT THIS MEASURE
AND HOPE IT WAS FORCED DAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I'VE.
DOOR ROSE WITH THE LEAGUE OF
WOMEN VOTERS TO CALIFORNIA HIGH.
THE LEAGUE IS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB TWO ONE TWO THREE IT'S
REALLY AN AND ADJUSTMENT TO MEET
THE ON THE GROUND REALITIES OF A
LOCAL REDISTRICTING. A
UNNECESSARY ADJUSTMENT. USE
DISTRICT ELECTIONS ARE INTENDED
TO ENCOURAGE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION AYE AND AND IT.
GIVE A MEANINGFUL VOICE TO
PEOPLE IN THE PROCESS
AND UNFORTUNATELY THE CURRENT
TIME FRAME REALLY DEFEATS THAT
PURPOSE BY. MAKING IT DIFFICULT
TO GAUGE UNDERREPRESENTED
COMMUNITIES IN PARTICULAR IN THE
PROCESS AND THEREFORE WE THINK
IT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT. TO
CREATE A MORE GENEROUS TIMELINE
THAT IS GOING TO INDEED. DE
EFFECTUATE THE THE INTENT OF THE
UNDERLYING LAW.
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THINK VERY
MUCH ADDITIONAL BONUSES.
NAMING ORGANIZATION
REPRESENTING IN SUPPORT PROMISE
YET SOME HAVE A CELL YOU OF
CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
POLITELY PUTTING ON BEHALF OF
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL FUND
ALSO IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH.
SECOND.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE A BRING IT BACK TO
THE.
MY COLLEAGUES FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS.
BUT YOU'RE HARPER.
THANK YOU. I APPRECIATE THE
DIFFICULT UP POSITION THAT THE
CITIES ARE AND I THERE'S BEEN A
CONCERTED EFFORT OVER TIME WITH
MULTIPLE PIECES OF LEGISLATION
TRYING TO BASICALLY FORCE A
CONVEYOR BELT.
THAT CITIES ARE PLACED ON TAPE
PROVIDE THEM.
BUT THE MAP LIKE PIECES OF PIE
AYE INTO THESE DISTRICTS WHERE
THEY WISH TO DO SO OR NOT.
SOME CITIES WANNA HAVE DISTRICTS
SOME CITIES DO NOT. BUT WHAT
THIS PROCESS IS BEEN DOING OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS IS THE
LEGISLATURE'S MAJORITY SPIN
IMPOSING ITS WILL ON LOCAL
COMMUNITIES WHETHER THEY WANTED.
UP INTO DISTRICTS ARE NOT.
I CAN'T BE A PART OF THAT I'M
SORRY I THINK THAT CITY'S
INSTEAD OF A CAPITULATING AND
SURRENDERING OUGHT TO STATE LAW
SHOULD FIGHT OF FOR THEIR
ABILITY TO BE ABLE TO HAVE SELF
DETERMINATION ON WHETHER THEY
CHOOSE TO HAVE DISTRICTS. OR NOT
THE VOTERS SHOULD BE ABLE TO
HAVE THE CHOICE ON WHETHER THEY
HAVE DISTRICTS OR NOT I DON'T
THINK THAT IT SHOULD BE AND.
A DEAL THAT'S DONE BY COUNCIL
MEMBERS AURA OR OTHER ELECTED
OFFICIALS TO IMPOSE ON THE
VOTERS THEMSELVES WITHOUT THE
VOTERS EVENTUALLY BEING ABLE TO
HAVE THE SAY ON WHETHER OR NOT
TO HAVE DISTRICT.
I APPRECIATE THE ATTEMPT I TO
TRY TO MAKE IT EASIER UP FOR
CITIES TO DEAL WITH A LOT OF
THERE BEING DEALT BUT INSTEAD I
THINK THAT LEGISLATORS SHOULD
STAND UP. AND REVERSE THIS
COURSE AND ALLOW CITIES TO BE
ABLE HAVE THE SELF DETERMINATION
ON THIS ISSUE THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO IN MY PAIN.
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE
WILL PROVIDE. A INCENTIVES TO
OUR.
THE TOUR COMMUNITIES TO PROVIDE
BETTER OUTREACH TO ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AND TRULY
APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT ON THIS
MEASURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
CALIFORNIA VOTING RIGHTS ACT IS
THAT A TRANSFORMATIVE EFFECT ON
THE WAY THE LOCAL OFFICIALS.
THE OUR ELECTED IN CALIFORNIA.
I WON A JURISDICTION IS DRAWING
DISTRICT LINES FOR THE FIRST
TIME WHEN MOVING FROM AT LARGE
TO JUST REPLACE ELECTIONS. IT IS
CRUCIALLY IMPORTANT THAT THERE
BE ADEQUATE TIME FOR PUBLIC
INPUT. BECAUSE THAT FIRST SET OF
DISTRICTS OFTEN ENDS UP SERVING
AS THE STARTING POINT FOR FUTURE
REDISTRICTING PLANS.
BECAUSE OF THAT.
I'M RECOMMENDING SUPPORT ON
THIS BILL.
I THINK YOU BRING AFFORD.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL ROLE
IN THE MOTION IS TO PASS THIS
AMENDED AND RE REFER TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE
BERMAN AYE HARPER. HARPER NO
CALDERON.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
WEBER.
WEBER I.
THE BILL IS ON CALL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
NEXT UP WE HAVE.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE BY SOME
NUMBER KILEY.
READY WHEN YOU ARE SIR.
RIGHT.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR.
THE VICE CHAIR AND I AND
MEMBERS.
JUST THREE DAYS AGO THIS MONTH
WAS THE ONE HUNDRED FIFTH
ANNIVERSARY
THE RATIFICATION.
THE SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT
THE UNITED STATES CON.
WHAT REQUIRES THAT EACH STATE'S
U. S. SENATORS
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE THERE OF?
BEFORE YOU'LL RECALL.
THEY WERE APPOINTED.
IN THE SPIRIT OF THE OCCASION
I'M PROPOSING LEGISLATION THAT
CLOSES WHAT U. S. SENATOR RUSS
FEINGOLD FINDEL HAS DESCRIBED AS
A LOOPHOLE IN THE LAW.
WONDERS ALOUD NATIONWIDE
HUNDRED NINETY SIX SENATORS TO
SERVE WITHOUT THE CONSENT
OF THE VOTERS IN CASES WITH A
PREDECESSOR WAS UNABLE TO SERVE
OUT THEIR FULL TERM.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE CLOSES ITS
WOULD PULL.
BUT REQUIRING THAT ALL U. S.
SENATE VACANCIES IN CALIFORNIA.
HE FILLED BY ELECTION.
IN SO DOING IT MAKES
CALIFORNIA'S PROCESS FOR FILLING
THE SENATE U. S. SENATE
VACANCIES.
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROCESS
ALREADY IN PLACE FOR FILLING
VACANCIES IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE AND AS OUR FORMER
OUR COLLEAGUE MR GOMEZ CAN TELL
YOU.
THE US HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
ON THE NATIONAL STAGE SUCH A
PROPOSAL HAS RECEIVED BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE SENATOR
FEINGOLD AUTHORED A
CONSTITUTIONAL AMENDMENT THAT
READ QUOTE. NO PERSON SHALL BE A
STATE SENATOR FROM THE STATE.
IN LAST SUCH PERSON HAS BEEN
ELECTED BY THE PEOPLE THAT ROB.
SENATOR FEINGOLD EXPLAINED
IT IS PAINFULLY CLEAR THAT
APPOINTMENTS ARE AN ANACHRONISM.
THAT MUST AND.
IN NINETEEN THIRTEEN THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT TO THE
CONSTITUTION.
GIVE CITIZENS OF THIS COUNTRY
THE POWER TO FINALLY ELECT THEIR
SENATORS.
THEY SHOULD HAVE THE SAME POWER.
IN THE CASE OF UNEXPECTED MID
TERM VACANCY.
THAT THE SENATE IS RESPONSIBLE
POSSIBLE TO THE WILL OF THE
PEOPLE.
THAT PROPOSAL WAS CO AUTHORED BY
SENATOR JOHN MCCAIN AND SENATOR
RICHARD DURBIN.
IT RECEIVED WIDE SUPPORT WAS
EVEN ENDORSED BY THE NEW YORK
TIMES AND PASSED IT JUDICIARY
SUBCOMMITTEE. IN THE DEMOCRATIC
CONTROLLED CONGRESS
AN EQUALLY BIPARTISAN MEASURE
WAS INTRODUCED AT THAT AT THE
SAME TIME IN THE HOUSE AND OF
THE HURDLES OF ENACTING WHAT
WOULD HAVE BEEN THE TWENTY
EIGHTH AMENDMENT. OPERATIVE TO
HIRE MEMBER AT THE VERY.
DIFFICULT PROCESS AND IT'S ONLY
BEEN.
ACCESSIBLE SEVENTEEN TIMES AND
THE BILL OF RIGHTS TO AMEND THE
US CONSTITUTION.
AT THE GOOD NEWS IS THAT HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE CAN ACHIEVE THAT
MEASURES GOALS FOR OUR STATE.
THROUGH LEGISLATIVE ACTION
ALERT.
AND THERE ARE SEVERAL COMPELLING
REASONS.
FIRST
IT WOULD BRING CALIFORNIA SYSTEM
FOR FILLING SENATE VACANCIES
IN LINE WITH THE SPIRIT OF THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT.
THE CONGRESSIONAL RECORD IS
CLEAR THAT THE INTENT OF THE
AMENDMENTS VACANCY BECAUSE.
HAD ALWAYS BEEN TO MODEL THE
FINAL THE FEELING OF SENATE
VACANCIES AS CLOSELY AS POSSIBLE
ON THE SYSTEM USED FOR FILLING
VACANCIES IN THE HOUSE WHERE
AGAIN SPECIAL ELECTIONS. ARE THE
RULE.
ACCORDING TO THE CONGRESSIONAL
RECORD OF MAY TWENTY THIRD.
NINETEEN ELEVEN THE AUTHOR OF
THE SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENTS
VACANCY BECAUSE
SENATOR JOSEPH BRISTOW.
EXPLAINED HOW HE HAD USED TO
QUOTE EXACTLY THE SAME LANGUAGE
AND DIRECTING THE GOVERNOR TO
CALL SPECIAL ELECTIONS
FOR THE ELECTIONS OF SENATOR THE
BILL VACANCIES THAT IS USED IN
THE CONSTITUTION. AND DIRECTING
HIM TO ISSUE WRITS OF ELECTION
TO FILL VACANCIES IN THE HOUSE
OF REPRESENTATIVES.
WELL IT IS THE CASE FROM THE
SEVENTEEN THE MOMENT ALLOW STATE
LEGISLATORS LEGISLATURES TO
EMPOWER THEIR GOVERNORS TO MAKE
TEMPORARY APPOINTMENTS TO THE
SENATE.
THESE APPOINTMENTS IF THEY
OCCURRED AT ALL WERE ALWAYS
MEANT TO BE JUST THAT TEMPORARY
LASTING ONLY SO LONG AS IT WOULD
TAKE TO ORGANIZE A SPECIAL
ELECTION.
THAT'S WHY THE VACANCY ACOSTA
PILATES THAT IN THE EVENT OF A
VACANCY. GOVERNOR'S QUOTE OF
EACH STATE SHALL ISSUE WRITS OF
ELECTION
THE BILL SUCH VACANCIES.
THE PROBLEM ARISES WHEN
GOVERNOR'S DETERMINED TO
ARTIFICIALLY LENGTHEN THE TENURE
OF APPOINTED SENATORS OFTEN
POLITICAL ALLIES.
MIGHT KNOWING THIS PROVISION.
IN CALIFORNIA ON ALL FIVE
OCCASIONS SINCE NINETEEN
THIRTEEN.
WHAT DO YOU WHAT SENATE VACANCY
HAS OCCURRED?
DEMOCRAT AND REPUBLICAN
GOVERNORS LIKE HAVE DECLINED TO
CALL A SPECIAL ELECTION.
IFILL THE U. S. SENATE VACANCY
NOTWITHSTANDING THEIR STOCK TO
THIRTY STATUTORY AUTHORITY.
TO DO SO.
THE RESULT IS THAT APPOINTMENTS
TO THE U. S. SENATE CAN LAST UP
TO TWO AND A HALF YEARS AND
IMPORTANTLY. THE APPOINTED
INDIVIDUAL CONSERVE FOR DECADES
PROVIDED HE OR SHE EVENTUALLY
WINS ELECTION AFTER ACQUIRING
THE ADVANTAGE OF INCUMBENCY
BY APPOINTMENT.
THIS POSES CHALLENGES TO THE
DEMOCRATIC PRINCIPLES OF OUR
STATE
SUE KELLY ARE YOU MOVING ON TO A
THIRD PAGE OF SINGLE. LINE
COMMENTS AND I I'M VERY GOOD
VERY CLOSE MISTER
I DO THINKBUDGET HISTORY ISN'T
AND I'M SURE THAT ALL OF YOUR
COLLEAGUES READ.
YOUR YOUR PURPOSE FOR THE BILL
I APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I APPRECIATE THE CHANCE
TO I. FINISH MY REMARKS WHICH WE
ARE VERY CLOSE TO.
SO I THOSE EXPLAINING AND THIS
POSES CHALLENGES TO DEMOCRATIC
PRINCIPLES OF ACCOUNTABILITY.
TIME AND IT WAS THESE VERY
CHALLENGES THE SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT CALLING FOR THE DIRECT
ELECTION OF SENATORS.
WAS DESIGNED TO RESULT.
I AM AND YOU KNOW YOU CAN
ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE ARGUMENTS
THAT WERE MADE BY AGAINST
POLITICAL APPOINTMENTS BY THOSE
WHO WERE IN FAVOR OF THE
SEVENTEENTH AMENDMENT. I IN THE
WORDS OF ONE JOURNALIST OF THE
DAY I SYSTEM BY APPOINTMENT MORE
OFTEN THAN NOT HAD ALLOWED
SENATE SEATS TO BE QUOTE
INDIRECTLY BOUGHT BY
CONTRIBUTION TO PARTY FUNDS AND
OTHER OUTLAYS MORALLY CORRUPT.
WE CAN SEE MOST FAMOUSLY IN THE
CASE OF ROBERT BOY* EFFORTS
TO APPOINT A SUCCESSOR TO FORMER
US SENATOR BARACK OBAMA. THAT
THE ARGUMENT STILL APPLIES TO
THE PLANET PRESENT I YOU MIGHT
RECALL WILL GO THAT'S WAS
RECORDED SAYING I'M MAKING A
SLIGHT CHANGE TO ONE WORD HERE
TO KEEP THINGS PGP. I'VE GOT
THIS THING AND IT'S FREAKING
GOLD.
OTHER EXAMPLES OF NEPOTISM OR
WORSE ABOUND REPUBLICAN GOVERNOR
FRANK MAKOWSKI IN ALASKA OF
COURSE APPOINTED HIS OWN
DAUGHTER TO THE U. S. SENATE.
TWO SENATORS WHERE THE SPOUSES
OF THE GOVERNOR WHO APPOINTED
THEM.
IN NINE INSTANCES GOVERNORS HAVE
BUILT A VACANT SENATE SEAT BY
POINTING.
THEMSELVES.
BUT EVEN SHORT OF CORRUPTION OR
NEPOTISM IT IS STILL THE CASE
THAT GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENTS
TEND TO VIOLATE THE POPULAR
WELL.
U. S. SENATORS ARE IN MANY WAYS
OUR STATE AMBASSADORS OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE ONLY GET
TWO OF THEM THERE ARE NO TERM
LIMITS THEIR INFLUENCE ON THE
AFFAIRS OF OUR STATE AND THE
COUNTRY CAN BE PROFOUND. AND
VOTERS DO NOT NECESSARILY SEEK
THE SAME QUALITIES IN A SENATOR
BUT THEY DO IN THE GOVERNOR.
TODAY WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
CORRECT THESE DEFICIENCIES.
VACANCIES IN THE SENATE AS I'VE
EXPLAINED ARE RELATIVELY RARE
HAPPENING ON AVERAGE ONLY ONCE
EVERY TWENTY FIVE YEARS PER
STATE.
BUT WHEN THOSE VACANCIES DO
OCCUR IT'S IMPORTANT THAT OUR
CITIZENS ARE NOT
DISENFRANCHISED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND OUT
WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF OF CAL
ABOUT CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE IS
JAKE LOCKER.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS
MORNING.
I SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF SB TWENTY
FIVE TWELVE WHICH PROTECTS
CALIFORNIANS SEVENTEENTH
AMENDMENT RIGHT TO DIRECTLY
ELECT THEIR UNITED STATES
SENATORS.
WE A COMMON CAUSE BELIEVE THAT
FILLING THE SENATE VACANCY.
DECISION FAR TOO IMPORTANT TO
LEAVE TO ONE PERSON.
A US SENATOR FROM CALIFORNIA IS
ONE OF MOST POWERFUL AND
INFLUENTIAL OFFICIALS IN THE
COUNTRY. REPRESENTING NEARLY
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE.
CALIFORNIANS SHOULD NOT HAVE TO
WAIT UP TO TWO YEARS TO CHOOSE
WHO WILL BE THEIR STATEWIDE
REPRESENTATIVE ON THE NATIONAL
STAGE.
WELL AN APPOINTMENT IS CHEAPER
AND FASTER THAN A SPECIAL
ELECTION
A SPECIAL ELECTION IS INHERENTLY
MORE DEMOCRATIC.
APPOINTMENTS ARE EFFECTIVELY
ELECTIONS DECIDED BY AN
ELECTORATE OF ONE.
AND THERE'S NO CHECKER
SAFEGUARDING THE CURRENT PROCESS
AGAINST THE GOVERNOR APPOINTING
A SENATOR WHO IS ON
REPRESENTATIVE STATE.
ADDITIONALLY AND APPOINTED
SENATOR WOULD RECEIVE A MAJOR
UNEARNED INCUMBENCY ADVANTAGE
TOWARDS RETAINING THEIR SEATS.
AN APPOINTEE WOULD HAVE UP TO
TWO YEARS TO BUILD UP NAME
RECOGNITION. GARNER ENDORSEMENTS
AND SOLICIT CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS FROM A POSITION OF
POWER BEFORE EVER RECEIVING
ABOUT.
GIVEN THE HUGE ADVANTAGE THAT
INCUMBENTS RECEIVE IN ELECTIONS.
AND IT SENATORS OFTEN SERVE FOR
DECADES ON AND. THE INFLUENCE OF
A SENATORIAL APPOINTMENT COULD
LINGER FAR BEYOND THE NEXT
REGULARLY SCHEDULED ELECTION.
FINALLY S. B. TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
WILL LIKELY HAVE A BENEFICIAL
DETERRENT EFFECT.
SENATORS CONCURRENTLY TIME THEIR
RESIGNATION RETIREMENT SO THEY
COULD HOLD SOME SWAY OVER WHO
WAS CHOSEN AS THEIR SUCCESSOR.
OR AT LEAST OVER WHICH GOVERNOR
CHOOSES THEIR REPLACEMENT.
UNDER AB TWENTY FIVE TWELVE
HOWEVER SENATORS WOULD HAVE NO
INCENTIVE TO LEAVE THEIR TERMS
EARLY.
FOR THESE REASONS CALIFORNIA COM
BECAUSE SUPPORTS AB TWENTY FIVE
TWELVE.
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS RIGHT TO
CHOOSE WHO REPRESENTS THEM IN
WASHINGTON.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SING NOW BRING BACK MY
COLLEAGUES FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
LESS YOUR HARBOR. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR SOME OF
THE SOME OF THOSE EXAMPLES I
DIDN'T REALIZE HOW STRIKING VIA
THE INSTANCES OF NEPOTISM MORE
IN TERMS OF OF THESE ISSUES. UP
BUT WHEN I ASKED MY STAFF TO GET
SOME INFORMATION THEY FOUND
THAT.
THAT MANY STATES ACTUALLY DO
SPECIAL ELECTION ALABAMA LIKE
ALASKA. CONNECTICUT LOUISIANA
MASSACHUSETTS MISSISSIPPI NORTH
DAKOTA OKLAHOMA OREGON RHODE
ISLAND TAXES VERMONT WASHINGTON
AND WISCONSIN
STATES THAT OUR SMALL STATES
THERE LARGE OBVIOUSLY A SPECIAL
ELECTION LIKE THIS ISFEASIBLE
WHETHER IT'S A SMALL STATE OR
LARGE STATE.
I THINK THAT THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT WE CAN DEFINITELY DO HERE
IN THE CITY CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU VERY SURE HARPER.
THE.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR A MOTION AND A
SECOND MISS HARPER.
AND.
OUT OF A COURTESY ADD TO MY
COLLEAGUE AND FRIEND THANK YOU I
WILL SECOND EVEN THOUGH I WILL
NOT SUPPORT.
YOU'RE VERY COURTEOUS YES SIR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. AYE AYE
YEAH I JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE I THINK THAT YOU
KNOW THIS IS A SENSIBLE MEASURE
AND I I ACTUALLY REALLY
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS I THOUGHT IT WAS SUPER
INTERESTING AND THAT. AND WELL
DONE AND I ACTUALLY LEARNED
QUITE A BIT FROM IT AND THAT
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF GOOD
POINTS RAISED AYE IN IT AS WELL
I THINK A LOT OF THE ISSUES
RAISED ARE AT SOMEWHAT
LOGISTICAL NATURE.
YOU KNOW ON THEIR WAY TO
COMPRESS THE TIMELINE FOR
EXAMPLE SO I AM I JUST AFTER THE
COMMITTEE'S CONSIDERATION TODAY
IN ENDORSING THE PRINCIPLE THAT
WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO CHOOSE. OUR
US SENATORS AND I'D BE VERY AYE
OPEN TO US SORTA WORKING ON
THESE WILL JUST WHAT'S
LOGISTICAL ASPECTS GOING FORWARD
SET THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
KILEY.
AS HE ANNOUNCES POINTS OUT.
.
MY CONCERN IS THAT THIS IS A
SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF A PROBLEM
THAT CREATES MORE PROBLEMS.
AND THE REASON I SAY THAT IS A
TWO FOLD ONE IS HEARING
CALIFORNIA WE GOT FIVE
SITUATIONS
A OF GOVERNOR GUBERNATORIAL
APPOINTMENTS AND AND ONLY IN.
FORTY PERCENT OF THOSE IN INTO
ARE THE FIVE HAS THE APPOINTED
SENATOR.
SUCCESSFULLY RUN FOR REELECTION.
IN ONE OF THE FIVE CASES THAT
CHOSE NOT TO RUN INTO THE FIVE
THEY RAN IN THE SUBSEQUENT
ELECTION LOST SO VOTERS DID HAVE
A CHANCE TO WEIGH IN.
AND THE VOTERS WAITED AND THEN
AND DECIDED THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
APPOINTEE WAS NOT THE
APPROPRIATE PERSON.
I'D NATIONWIDE.
SINCE NINETEEN THIRTEEN.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN SENATORS
HAVE BEEN APPOINTED BY THIS
PRIOR TO TWENTY SEVENTEEN WHO
SUBSEQUENTLY SOUGHT A ELECTION
AND OUT OF THAT FIFTY TWO AND A
HALF PERCENT WHO PURSUED
ELECTION WERE SUCCESSFUL. AND
FORTY SEVEN AND A HALF PERCENT
WERE DEFEATED SO IT'S KIND OF A
COIN FLIP A IN TERMS OF WHETHER
OR NOT THE VOTERS.
GONNA VALIDATE THE GOVERNOR BIG
GUBERNATORIAL APPOINTMENT BUT
THE PROBLEM IS THAT IT CREATES
ARE ARE NUMEROUS AND I THINK
SIGNIFICANT.
ONE IS COST.
AND A SPECIAL STATEWIDE
ELECTION FOR FOR U. S. SENATE
WILL COST A TOTAL OF TWO IT UP
TO TWO HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE PRIMARY.
A HUNDRED MILLION FOR THE
GENERAL OF THE MORE IMPORTANTLY
THAN THAT THAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND ARE ALMOST FORTY
MILLION PEOPLE.
WOULD HAVE TO BE ABSENT OF A
VOICE OF A CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
VOICE IN IT BODY WORK CALIFORNIA
IS ALREADY UP UNDERREPRESENTED
BASED ON OUR POPULATION AND WE.
COULD.
WE WOULD ONLY HAVE ONE
REPRESENTATIVE IN THE U. S.
SENATE.
WHICH CAN BE CRITICAL AS WE'VE
SEEN TO A LOT OF LEGISLATION AT
ARGUE TERRIBLE LEGISLATION
GETTING PAST.
IN THE U. S. SENATE.
IN ADDITION TO THAT.
.
IN A BIGGER CONCERN IS THAT IF
WE WERE TO MAKE THIS CHANGE IT
WILL CREATE A SYSTEM WHERE ONLY
WEALTHY PEOPLE WOULD EVEN HAVE A
CHANCE OF WINNING.
BECAUSE BY HAVING A SPECIAL
ELECTION FOR U. S. SENATE.
A PRIMARY OCCURRING BETWEEN TWO
TO FIVE MONTHS A AFTER THE RIGHT
RESIGNATION OR DEATH OF A U. S.
SENATOR.
YOU WHO IT.
WHAT NORMAL PERSON CAN WRAP UP A
CAMPAIGN IN CALIFORNIA?
TO IT TO GET THE MESSAGE OUT TO
SO MANY PEOPLE SO QUICKLY AND SO
THAT MEANS THAT THAT.
YOU KNOW THE ONLY PEOPLE THAT
COULD POSSIBLY WIN ARE PEOPLE
WHO CAN SOLVE FUND THEIR
CAMPAIGNS.
AND AND THAT'S REALLY A
TERRIBLE THING I THINK FOR FOR
THE OVERALL POPULATION SO. I
APPRECIATE. THE VERY THOROUGH
ANALYSIS BY MY MY COLLEAGUE AND
FRIEND.
BUT FOR THAT THE CONCERNS THAT
I EXPRESSED BY I'M NOT ABLE TO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE AND AND
RECOMMENDED NO VOTE.
WITH THAT MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN. BERMAN NO
HARPER.
YEAH HARPER AYE CALDERON.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH WEBER.
SO THAT'S A ON CALL THANK YOU
MISTER JACKSON FAMOUS GARLIC.
WITHIN THAT.
THAT'S ALL WE HAVE.
NO WE HAVE IT'S OWN PEOPLE HAVE
SIGNED UP SO LET'S SEE NO CHORE.
LEVINE.
IS THAT PERFECT.
ALL THAT'S RIGHT MISTER HARPER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO PRESENT YOUR
BILL IN THIS OBERNOLTE BILL I'D
BE HAPPY TO MISTER.
NO GO AHEAD AND START WITH MY
BILL AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
THANK YOU SIR.
AND I'LL GO AHEAD MOVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
I THINK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THANK YOU.
TODAY I HEAR I HEAR PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY. THIS IS A BIPARTISAN
MEASURE AS EVIDENCE OUT BY THE
MOTION OF WILLS AUTHORIZED LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO BE ABLE CONTRACT
WITH THE FAIR POLITICAL
PRACTICES COMMISSION.
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS THE F.
PPC.
THE ADMINISTRATION FORSMAN OF
LOCAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND
GOVERNMENT ETHICS LAWS.
THE F. BBC ENFORCES THE
POLITICAL REFORM ACT WHICH IS
THE MAIN LAW THE GOVERNOR STATE
ELECTION CAMPAIGNS AND
GOVERNMENT ETHICS.
THEY MAY IMPOSE ADMINISTRATIVE
FINES
AGAINST THOSE WHO VIOLATE THE
ACT LAST YEAR THE COMMISSION
COLLECTED MORE THAN ONE POINT
ONE MILLION DOLLARS IN FINES
FROM ELECTED OFFICIALS LOBBYISTS
AND POLITICAL DONORS. AND OTHERS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN.
EVEN THOUGH THE POLITICAL REFORM
ACT ALLOWS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
ADOPT THEIR OWN ORDINANCES TO
GOVERN CAMPAIGNS FOR LOCAL
PUBLIC A POLITICAL OFFICE. THE
FPP SEE DOES NOT HAVE AUTHORITY
OVER THOSE ELECTIONS
INSTEAD THE ENFORCEMENT OF THESE
LOCAL ORDINANCES IS TYPICALLY
LEFT TO THE CITY ATTORNEY OR THE
COUNTY DISTRICT ATTORNEY.
SINCE MOST LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
LACK THE EXPERIENCE
INVESTIGATING OR PROSECUTING
CAMPAIGN VIOLATIONS THERE IS
VERY OFTEN LITTLE OR NO
ENFORCEMENT ON THESE LOCAL
CAMPAIGN LOTS.
IN RECENT YEARS THE LEGISLATURE
HAS PASSED FOR BILLS THAT DO
PROVIDE EXCEPTIONS EXTENDING
AUTHORIZATION
A DIFFERENT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THE CONTRACT WITH THE AT PPC FOR
ENFORCEMENT OF THEIR CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ORDINANCES WHAT I WOULD
CONSIDER PILOT PROJECTS IF YOU
WILL.
EACH BILL RECEIVED NEAR
UNANIMOUS BIPARTISAN SUPPORT.
THIS BILL WOULD GIVE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS THE ABILITY TO BRING
COST EFFECTIVE.
SPURIOUS INDEPENDENT AND
IMPARTIAL ENTITY TO INVESTIGATE
CAMPAIGN FINANCE
OR OTHER GOVERNMENT ETHICS
VIOLATIONS AND BRING ACTIONS
AGAINST THESE VIOLATORS.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY IS NICOLAS HERE. FOR THE
UC COMMON CAUSE AND IS MORE ROB
RAMAN FROM THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT YOU'RE MUCH.
CHAIR MEMBERS A NICHOLAS ITEM
WITH CALIFORNIA COME BECAUSE
VERY PROUD SPONSOR AB TWENTY
EIGHT EIGHTY WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
AN IMPORTANT FORCE AN OPTION.
FOR LOCAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE AND
ETHICS ORDINANCES NO COST TO THE
STATE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW OTHER THAN
DISCLOSURE RULES THERE NO
CAMPAIGN FINANCE LIMITS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL HOWEVER LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS DO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO ENACT THEIR OWN CAMPAIGN
FINANCE ORDINANCES. FOR MANY DO
SO IN FACT WELL OVER HUNDRED
JURISDICTIONS HAVE ENACTED LOCAL
ORDINANCES WHICH WE THINK IS A
VERY GOOD THING.
FOR LARGE JURISDICTIONS LIKE LOS
ANGELES SAN DIEGO ORANGE COUNTY
ESTABLISHING AN ETHICS
COMMISSION IS AN EFFECTIVE AND
FEASIBLE MEANS FOR DOING
ENFORCEMENT FOR THESE
ORDINANCES.
BUT AS THE AUTHORS MENTION FOR
MANY OTHER JURISDICTIONS
PARTICULARLY SMALLER AND MID
SIZE JURISDICTIONS IT CAN BE
DIFFICULT TO AFFORD ESTABLISHING
AN ETHICS COMMISSION.
AS A CONSEQUENCE IT GENERALLY
RELY ON THE CITY ATTORNEY OR
DISK TURNING FOR ENFORCEMENT.
BUT AS A RESULT UNFORTUNATELY
LOCAL FORCE INTENSITY RARE. AS
THE OTHER MENTION MANY CASES
LOCAL CITY ATTORNEYS ARE DA'S
DON'T HAVE EXPERIENCE IN FORCING
CAMPAIGN FINANCE RULES. MOREOVER
THEY OFTEN OF OTHER PRIORITIES
SO FOR EXAMPLE DISTRICT ATTORNEY
WHEN DECIDING HOW TO PRIORITIZE
OUR RESOURCES MORE LIKELY TO
PROSECUTE VIOLENT CRIME
OBVIOUSLY THAN A CAMPAIGN
FINANCE VIOLATION WHICH MAKES
SENSE.
FINALLY THERE'S ALSO RISK OF THE
APPEARANCE OF POLITICAL BIAS
WHEN YOU HAVE A CITY ATTORNEY
WHO'S APPOINTED BY INCUMBENTS ON
THE CITY COUNCIL OR ELECTED
DISTRICT ATTORNEY. I'D DOING
PROSECUTIONS WITHIN A POLITICAL
RACE.
I AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY FOR ALL
THESE REASONS WOULD ALLOW LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS BY MUTUAL
AGREEMENT ACCORDINGLY CONTRACT
VIA PPC FOR THE ENFORCEMENT OF
LOCAL ORDINANCE.
BECAUSE IF PPC SPECIALIZES IN
CAMPAIGN ENFORCEMENT AND USES AN
ADMINISTRATIVE PROCESS WE
BELIEVE THIS WILL STREAMLINING
CRATE FOR MORE COST EFFECTIVE
LOCAL ENFORCEMENT. AT A FRACTION
OF THE COST OF SETTING UP AN
INDEPENDENT ETHICS COMMISSION.
MOREOVER THE EFFICACY IS HIGHLY
RESPECTED AS AN IMPARTIAL BODY
MAKING FOR SOME LESS
CONTROVERSIAL LOCALLY.
FINALLY BECAUSE IT REPORT CARMEN
PARTS LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO PAY
FOR THE SERVICE THERE SHOULD BE
NO COST OF STATE.
I AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY AS WAS
MENTIONED IS EXPANDING A
SUCCESSFUL BIPARTISAN MODEL A
WHICH IS ALREADY BEEN
ESTABLISHED IN THREE CITIES
INCLUDING SACRAMENTO STOCKTON
SAN AND BURNED YOU KNOW COUNTY
MODEL. SAVE BEEN HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL LEADING TO MORE
EDUCATION OF CANDIDATES ON LOCAL
ORDINANCE REQUIREMENTS THOSE
MORE ENFORCEMENT AND HAD BEEN
THE CASE.
SO TO CONCLUDE AB TWENTY EIGHT
EIGHTY PROVIDES IMPORTANT
ENFORCE AN OPTION IT'S ANOTHER
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX TO MAKE
LOCAL CAMPAIGN FINANCE
ORDINANCES MORE EFFECTIVE. AND
MORE FROM AYE EASILY ENFORCED.
FINALLY AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ALSO LIMITS IN THE FOR FUTURE
SPECIAL LEGISLATION BY OPENING
THE SOLE AUTHORITY TO OTHER
JURISDICTIONS.
A RELYING ON SPECIALIZATION CAN
DELAY BY MORE THAN A YEAR THE
ABILITY OF LOCAL GOVERNMENT
TENSIONS OF THIS CONTRACT WHICH
REVIEWS A HUGE BENEFIT TO THIS
BILL.
SEVERAL THESE REASONS WERE VERY
PROUD SPONSOR THIS BILL AND URGE
KNIFE.
I THINK VERY MUCH.
GOOD MORNING WAS MARATHON ON
BEHALF OF THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA.
I CONCUR WITH THE COMMENTS MADE
BY MISTER HIGH DOOR AND IT WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO ADD THAT THIS BILL
WOULD AUTHORIZE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONTRACT WITH THE
F. PPC. FOR THE ADMIN COULD IT
REALLY FOR PUBLIC
OFFICE AND PROVIDE EFFECTIVE
MONITORING AND ENFORCEMENT
LASTLY WE'D LIKE TO THANK.
MISTER HARPER FOR AUTHORING JUST
IMPORTANT MEASURE THINKING.
THE YOU'RE MUCH.
THE POLITICAL
GOTCHA.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. PLEASE.
PATRICK LANG PRESIDENT EXECUTIVE
PER OF THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN WE ARE STRONGLY
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING FORWARD IT REALLY IS
IMPORTANT TO GIVE US A. SMALL
AND LOCAL JURISDICTIONS IT
BETTER ENFORCEMENT OPTION.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS DANE
HUTCHINGS WITH A LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES I'M ALSO FROM
MY COLLEAGUE.
DEAING GIVEN FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION TRANSPORT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ME
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS PAT RAN
WITH AND READING ASSOCIATE
TRIPLING THE ORANGE COUNTY
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION. A WE'VE
HAD ISSUES WITH THE BILL IN THE
PAST.
BUT.
JUST SO I'M CLEAR THIS IS
PROPOSED TO BE AMENDED.
CORRECT YET OR JURISDICTIONS
UNDER THREE MILLION YES WITH
THAT AMENDMENT. WILL REMOVE OUR
OPPOSITION FROM THE BILL THANK
YOU VERY MAKE YOU THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES.
AND SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION OR
NEUTRAL.
SEEING NINE BRING IT BACK TO
MYSELF.
LOOKING FOR A SECOND MR ARBOR.
OF.
MY SECOND IN MY OWN BILL I I I I
MADE THE MOTION AND NO ONE ELSE
IS IN ORDER SHALL BE HAPPY TO
SIDE RECOMMEND.
LEAVE OF THE CARE.
THEY'D YOU SIR.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD AND FOR WORKING
WITH THE COMMITTEE ON AMENDMENTS
TO ADDRESS THE CONCERNS RAISED
IN THE ANALYSIS. WHILE THE FTP
SEES AGREEMENT TO ENFORCE SAN
BERNARDINO IS CAMPAIGN FINANCE
OR ITS HAS BEEN SUCCESSFUL
THAT'S CURRENTLY THE ONLY JURORS
THERE ARE ONLY LOCAL ORDINANCE
THAT THAT BE PCS AND FORCE THUS
FAR. BECAUSE OF THAT.
I WOULD FIND IT HARD TO JUSTIFY
A PERMANENT EXPANSION THAT WOULD
ALLOW THAT PP SEE TO ENFORCE
LOCAL CAMPAIGN ETHICS LAWS FOR
ANY JURISDICTION WITH A
POPULATION. OF LESS THAN THREE
MILLION PEOPLE WITHOUT FURTHER
EVALUATION BY THE LEGISLATURE US
SO I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
WILLINGNESS TO TAKE THE
AMENDMENTS LISTEN COMMON NUMBER
EIGHT OF THE ANALYSIS. WHICH
REQUIRES THAT THE PC TO REPORT
TO THE LEGISLATURE ON THE STATUS
OF THE AGREEMENTS ENTERED INTO.
AND ADDS A SEVEN YEAH THAT'S A
SEVEN YEAR SUNSET CLAUSE AND IT
PERMITS THE AT PPC TO TERMINATE
AN AGREEMENT AS SPECIFIED IN
ADDITION AS WAS MENTIONED COMMON
NUMBER ONE CONTAINS AUTHORS
AMENDMENTS.
WHICH PROVIDE THAT THIS BILL
DOES NOT APPLY TO A JURISDICTION
WITH A POPULATION OF THREE
MILLION OR MORE WITH THOSE
AMENDMENTS I'M RECOMMENDING.
SUPPORT VOTE MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE HARPER AYE AYE HARPER
AYE CALLED ROOM. MCCARTY MULLIN.
STEINORTH WEBER.
THE BILL THAT DOES ON CALL.
WHEN WE MOVE ON TO AB TWENTY
THREE SEVENTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN.
TODAY.
I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE ON BEHALF OF OF MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAY
OBERNOLTE. AYE AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FIVE ALLOWS THE
SECRETARY OF STATE.
TO ENROLL CALIFORNIA IN THE
ELECTRONIC REGISTRATION
INFORMATION CENTER OR ERIC.
ERIC IS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
GOVERNMENT MANAGED BY ITS MEMBER
STATES.
AND WHICH WAS FORMED TO IMPROVE
THE ACCURACY OF AMERICA'S VOTER
ROLLS AIR COMPARES MEMBER STATES
VOTER ROLLS AGAINST SEVERAL
DATABASES INCLUDING THE DMV
SOCIAL SECURITY RECORDS. TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY STATES BORDER
ROLES ARE AS UP TO DATE AS
POSSIBLE ALLOWING MEMBER STATES.
A CLEAN UP THEIR VOTER ROLLS AND
HELP IDENTIFY INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY NEED TO REGISTER SUCH AS
SOMEONE WHO MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
FROM ANOTHER STATE.
THE AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO COMMIT
TO WORK WITH YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN.
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS IN THE NEXT
COMMITTEE PRIVACY.
CLAIRE FIVE ERIC MUST BE
CALIFORNIA'S SECURITY STANDARDS
BEFORE WE SUBMIT. OUR ANY OF OUR
VOTER INFORMATION I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU MISTER HARPER ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE OUT NOPE SEEM NOT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CHEN MEMBERS MANY ITS ROMANCE
YES I'M AND NEARLY HALF OF A SO
YOU OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE HAVE CONCERNS.
BUT PRIMARILY BUT AND THE
PRIVACY IMPLICATIONS THIS BILL
THE TRANSFERRING OF DATA
WITHOUT.
THE CONTENT OF VOTERS.
AM TO A NON GOVERNMENTAL THIRD
PARTY IN PARTICULAR IS
CONCERNING.
AND WE THINK IT'S CONTRARY TO
PRIVACY STATUTES IN.
THE GOVERNMENT CODE THE MOTOR
VEHICLE CODES. AND THE CIVIL
CODE.
AND I APPRECIATE.
THE AUTHORS
IS WILLING TO ADMIT COMMITMENTS
THE BILL BUT I THINK IT EXCEPT
AMEND. THE GOVERNMENT CODE THE
CIVIL CODE AND AT THE MOTOR
VEHICLE CODE. TO NOT BEING
CONTRARY TO THOSE PRIVACY
STATUTES.
I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT
POTENTIAL BOSS POSITIVES THAT
COME WITH ERIC AND THAT.
THE ANNOUNCES THE BILL NOTES
WHAT.
AND WHAT HAPPENED WAS COTTON
RECENTLY IN FEBRUARY THEY WERE
POTENTIALLY THOUSANDS OF VOTERS
WHO WERE.
FALSELY. AT.
THAT THERE WERE POTS POSITIVES
THAT THEY HAD AND HAD MOVED AND
THEY SHOWED UP.
I AM ON ELECTION DAY AND WERE
NOT ON THE ROLLS.
SO LET'S.
ANOTHER CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL
AND AND I I THINK IT'S ALSO
CALIFORNIA'S ALREADY. AM EVEN
ACTED A NUMBER OF REFORMS THAT
HAVE THE OPTION TO CLEAN UP OUR
ROLES. AND I HAD PEOPLE TO THE
ROLES WHICH I THINK IS IS
THE AIM OF ERIC.
AND THAT INCLUDES A NUMBER OF
REFORMS AT AT THE DMV WE HAVE
STREAMLINED REGISTRATION AT THE
DMV NOW THE GAME IS ALSO
ALLOWING VOTERS TO UPDATE THE
REGISTRATION TO THEY MOVE
BETWEEN COUNTIES.
WHICH IS NEW AMBER ALSO
LAUNCHING I'M.
ASSN DAVID AT INTERRUPT RUSSELL
LUNCHING AUTOMATIC REGISTRATION
AT DMB WHICH ISN'T WHICH
SHOULD.
AND
RESEARCH ON ITS POTENTIAL TED
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO OUR ROLES.
AND THE STATE IS LESS THAN A
YEAR AND A HALF INTO THE LAUNCH
OF VOTE COUNT WHICH THAT SHOULD
ALLOW FOR THE CLEANING UP OUR
ROLES AND AND THE SHARING OF
DATA BETWEEN COUNTIES. AND THIS
IS THE FIRST YEAR WITH THE
GENERAL AND IN A GENERAL
ELECTION RIVER GOING THAT SAME
DAY REGISTRATION AND EVERY
COUNTY. WHICH ANOTHER
OPPORTUNITY TO ADD VOTERS THE
ROLES AND GIVE VOTERS A CAPTAIN
WHO MAY HAVE SLIPPED THROUGH THE
CRACKS RICHARD ABOUT. IT WE
THINK
SUPPORT TO LET THOSE REFORMS
PLAY OUT BEFORE WE AND.
IT CAN BE DRASTIC STEP WHICH I
HAVE
THAT.
AT THE PRICE YOU ARE VOTERS AT
RISK AND.
ALSO HAS THE POTENTIAL OF
FALSELY REMOVING VOTERS AND
THEY'RE AWESOME WE FOUND.
ACTUALLY AT OPPOSE THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND THE ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
DOT A THE MAN WE NEED A MOTION
AND A SECOND SOME OF SECOND.
PROJECT CLOSE.
I THINK YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER
CHAIRMAN THANK YOU FOR THE
DISCUSSION I WANT TO NOTE THAT
THAT TWENTY OTHER STATES ARE
CURRENTLY A MEMBER OF ERIC IT'S
A MAINSTREAM IT'S WIDESPREAD.
ARE ASSEMBLYMAN ALTER OBERNOLTE
HAS MADE THE COMMITMENT TO WORK
ON AMENDMENTS TO GUARANTEE THE
INFORMATION SECURITY.
THAT I THINK ARE SATIN WHAT'S
WAS EXPRESSED AS A CONCERN I
SAID IT DOES CONFORM WITH
CALIFORNIA'S SUCH SECURITY
STANDARDS.
ENDOWED WANTS TO MAKE SURE THAT
IT DOES INDEED I GET A TO THAT
IN THE PRIVACY COMMITTEE MISTER
CHAIRMAN ON BEHALF OF
ASSEMBLYMAN OLDER OBERNOLTE I'D
LIKE TO ASK FOR THE COMMITTEES
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THAT I'D LIKE TO THINK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IN FOR THE VICE CHAIR
FOR PRESENTING IT.
I AGREE THAT WE NEED TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO ENSURE WE
HAVE CLEAN AND ACCURATE VOTER
ROLLS HOWEVER I'M ALSO COGNIZANT
OF THE NEED TO PROTECT PRIVATE
VOTER INFORMATION. AND AS A
RESULT I AM SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL WITH AN AMENDMENT TO
REQUIRE THE SECRETARY OF STATE
TO MAKE A DETERMINATION. THAT
THE ART PROGRAM ADEQUATELY
PROTECTS VOTER INFORMATION
BEFORE THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
APPLIES FOR MEN.
FOR MEMBERSHIP BECAUSE THIS
BILL IS DOUBLE REFERRED TO THE
AUTHOR IS COMMITTED TO MAKING
THAT AMENDMENT AND PRIVACY
INCOME SUMMER PROTECTION
COMMITTEE WHICH I'M ALSO A
MEMBER OF.
ENDED WITH THAT COMMITMENT I'M
RECOMMENDING SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. AND THE MOTION IT.
NO GOOD.
YEAH.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RIVER
FOR TO PRIVACY AND CONSUMER
PROTECTION COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN AYE HARPER AYE.
HARPER AYE CALDERON.
IF IF IF I CALDERON AYE.
MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
WEBER.
SO THE BILL'S ON CALL.
IN I THINK ALL THAT'S LEFT ARE
MY BILLS.
THANK YOU RICHARD.
SO I'M GONNA TURN THE MEETING
OVER THE VICE CHAIR
I APPRECIATE THAT.
SO I'M GONNA START WITH.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY FIVE.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS.
I COME BEFORE THE COMMITTEE TO
PRESENT AB TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE
WHICH WOULD PROTECT MINERS
PRIVACY BY ENSURING THAT THE.
REGISTRATION INFORMATION OF
SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLDS
WHO HAVE PRE REGISTERED TO VOTE
IS NOT SUBJECT TO DISCLOSURE.
JUST LAST WEEK SECRETARY OF
STATE PATEA ALEX PADILLA
ANNOUNCED THAT OVER ONE HUNDRED
THOUSAND SIXTEEN AND SEVENTEEN
YEAR OLDS. HAVE PRE REGISTERED
TO VOTE SINCE THE STATE'S PRE
REGISTRATION PROGRAM LAUNCHED IN
SEPTEMBER TWENTY SIXTEEN.
I'M THRILLED THAT SO MANY YOUTH
HAVE TAKEN THIS CRITICAL STEP IN
BECOMING ENGAGED ACTIVE
PARTICIPANTS IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
AS MORE MINERS REGISTER TO VOTE
IT'S IMPERATIVE THAT THE
PRIVACY BY PROHIBITING THE
DISCLOSURE OF THEIR PERSONAL
INFORMATION. UNDER STATE LAW
CERTAIN VOTER REGISTRATION
INFORMATION INCLUDING NAMES HOME
ADDRESSES TELEPHONE NUMBERS AND
EMAIL ADDRESSES IS MADE
AVAILABLE FOR RESTRICTED USE BY
CAMPAIGNS. JOURNALISTS AND
ACADEMIC RESEARCHERS.
THE LAW IS UNCLEAR WHETHER
INFORMATION RELATED TO SIXTEEN
AND SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD PRE
REGISTRANTS CAN BE DISCLOSED IN
THE VOTER FILE.
AB TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE WILL
CLARIFY THAT THE INFORMATION OF
MINERS WHO WILL NOT BE EIGHTEEN
BY THE TIME OF THE NEXT ELECTION
BE KEPT CONFIDENTIAL. AND
PROHIBITED FROM DISCLOSURE.
THIS BILL WOULD ALSO EXPAND THE
EXISTING REPORTING REQUIREMENTS
TO ENSURE THAT COUNTIES THAT
COUNTIES ELECTIONS OFFICIALS
PROVIDE THE SECRETARY OF STATE.
WITH INFORMATION ON PERSONS WHO
HAVE PRE REGISTERED TO VOTE
COLLEAGUES I AM HEARTENED BY THE
EARLY ENGAGEMENT BY SOMEBODY
YOUTH AND IT IS OUR OBLIGATION
TO ENSURE THE PRIVACY OF MINORS.
A AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE WITH ME THAT.
TESTIFIED TODAY IS TIFFANY MOCK
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE AND MORE IMPORTANTLY SHE
WAS OF THE STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT AT PALO ALTO HIGH
SCHOOL WHEN I WAS A SENIOR. AND
SO WITH THAT. TIFFANY.
MAYBE YOU.
TIFFANY MARK IV HALF OF THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S.
ALEX VIDEOS OFFICE IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL HAPPY TO ASSIST WITH.
ALSO I GET IT.
GAY ANY OTHERS OUT WISHING TO
OUT IN ADDITION TO ON SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE ANY OPPONENTS OF THE
BILL.
SEEING NONE.
QUESTIONS AYE COMMENTS BY THE
COMMITTEE.
KATE SEEING NONE AGO HIDDEN
PERCENT.
RESPECT ASK DR VOTE THANK YOU.
PLEASE CHOLERA.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN HIGH. BERMAN
AYE HARPER.
I.
I
HARPER I CALLED AROUND.
CALDERON AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH AYE
WEBER.
FOUR ZERO THAT'S OUT FIGURE
MAKES BILL AND MISTER CHAIRMAN.
NEXT I WILL PRESENT.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE.
BOB HAS OF ELECTION
CYBERSECURITY THAT'S RIGHT.
IMPORTANT IMPORTANT THINGS.
AS YOU KNOW LAST MONTH THIS
COMMITTEE HELD A JOINT
INFORMATION ON HEARING ON THE
TOPIC OF ELECTION CYBERSECURITY.
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT TAKEAWAYS
FROM THAT HEARINGS THAT EXPERTS
BROADLY AGREE THAT THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE TO SUGGEST THAT VOTING
MACHINES OR VOTE OR VOTE
TALLYING IN CALIFORNIA OR
COMPROMISE DURING THE TWENTY
SIXTEEN ELECTION.
AND WHILE THERE WERE AND WHILE
THAT WAS A REASSURING IMPORTANT
MESSAGE FOR THE COMMITTEE AND
THE PUBLIC TO HEAR. THE FEDERAL
STATE AND COUNTY OFFICIALS AND
OTHER EXPERTS WHO TESTIFIED AT
THE HEARING ALL AGREED THAT WE
CANNOT BE COMPLACENT BECAUSE
THERE'S NO REASON TO BELIEVE
THAT THE CYBER THREATS TO OUR
ELECTIONS ARE GOING AWAY.
IN FACT IN THE EXPERT WITNESSES
AT THE HEARING EMPHASIZED THE
NEED FOR CONTINUED COMMITMENT TO
IDENTIFYING IN RESPONDING TO
CYBER THREATS.
ONE OF THE RECURRING THEMES THAT
EMERGED DURING THE TESTIMONY AT
THE IN FROM AT THE INFORMATIONAL
HEARING. IS THAT MAXIMIZING THE
CITY CYBERSECURITY OF OUR STATES
ELECTIONS WILL REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES DEDICATED
TO THAT PURPOSE.
IN PARTICULAR MANY WITNESSES
EMPHASIZE THE IMPORTANCE OF
INFORMATION SHARING AND
COORDINATED EFFORTS BETWEEN
FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES.
THAT'S ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
SMALLER COUNTIES THAT A MORE
LIMITED RESOURCES IN THEIR
ELECTIONS OFFICES
AND MUST RELY ON THE ASSISTANCE
THAT IS PROVIDED BY FEDERAL AND
STATE OFFICIALS. AND BY OTHER
EXTERNAL SOURCES.
AB THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE WOULD
CREATE THE OFFICE OF ELECTION
CYBERSECURITY WITHIN THE
SECRETARY OF STATE'S OFFICE.
THE.
THOUGH THE OFFICE OF.
YOU
THE OFFICE OF ELECTIONS A
CYBERSECURITY WOULD COORDINATE
EFFORTS BETWEEN FEDERAL STATE
LOCAL OFFICIALS INCLUDING COUNTY
REGISTRARS OF VOTERS TO REDUCE
THE LIKELIHOOD AND SEVERITY OF
CYBER INCIDENTS THAT THREATEN
THE INTEGRITY. OF CALIFORNIA
ELECTIONS.
MAYBE THIRTY SEVENTY FIVE IS
SUPPORTED BY SUGGESTED ON
EXPEDIA CALIFORNIA COMMON CAUSE
IN THE LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA THAT HAS NO OF
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FERNANDO.
PLEASE GO AHEAD FIFTEEN MARK IV
HALF OF THE SECRETARY SAID ALEX
PADILLA OR IN SUPPORT OF ACTION.
JACK WAGNER WITH COMMON CAUSE
ALSO SPORTING MEASURE.
ADDITIONAL OUR FOLKS A WISHING
TO EXPRESS A. LOT SUPPORT FOR
THE MEASURE EUROS LEGAL AND
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA EXPRESSING
SUPPORT I AM NOT A STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT HOWEVER. THAT.
THIS IS REALLY GOING TO GIVE
THE SECRETARY OF STATE THE MEANS
TO.
COMBAT.
I INCURSIONS INTO OUR ELECTIONS
AND AND.
A.
AVOID.
THE PROBLEM SAID BAD ACTORS THAT
WE ARE ALL CONCERNED ABOUT MAY
BRING IT UP WEEK ACTUALLY.
APPLAUD.
ASSEMBLYMAN BERMAN FOR FOCUSING
ON THE REAL THREATS TO OUR
ELECTIONS AS OPPOSED TO IMAGINE
THREATS TO OUR ELECTIONS.
AND WE REALLY LIKE THE VERY
THOUGHTFUL APPROACH
IN THIS BILL TO ESTABLISHING
BEST PRACTICES AND STATE OF THE
ART TECHNOLOGY AND DOING WHAT
CALIFORNIA DOES BEST.
BRINGING ALL OF THOSE THINGS
INTO PROTECTING CALIFORNIANS
ELECTIONS SO YOU WEEK STRONGLY
SUPPORT.
BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AND UP AGAIN WE'VE
ALREADY HAD THE OUR PUBLIC
COMMENTS AYE IN REGARDS TO THE
BILL AYE THOSE WISHING TO ADD I
JUST THEIR NAME AND AFFILIATION
AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
RYAN RONCO WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SAYS ASIA CLERKS IS A PATRICIA
ELECTION OFFICIALS ARCH SUPPORT
THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I ANY LA ONE WISHING TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO THE BILL.
SEEING NONE AYE QUESTIONS ARE
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
I EL JUST DIED HAVE MY MY OWN
ON.
I'M ALWAYS SKEPTICAL OF THE
CREATION OF ANY NEW OFFICE OR
DEPARTMENT.
OR DIVISION I I AGREE WITH THE
CONCERNS AND.
IN VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
HEARING THAT THERE COMMITTEE I
HAD IN REGARDS TO WAS
CYBERSECURITY ISSUES. I KNOW IT
IT THIS TIME I'M NOT PERSUADED
FOR THE CREATION OF A NEW OFFICE
I'LL STILL BE WILLING TO HEAR.
ARGUMENTS IN FAVOR OR OPPOSED
AS THIS BILL MOVES ON THROUGH
THE PROCESS SO AT THIS TIME OUT
BE.
NOT VOTING.
BUT.
I'LL BE ALL WATCHING THE
PROCESS IS.
AND WITH THOSE.
COMMENTS ON YOUR CLOTHES MISTER.
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR OF.
PICK UP PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOST THIS DEPRESSING RE
REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE.
BERMAN I HARPER UP VOTING HARPER
IS NOT VOTING CALDERON. CALDERON
AYE MCCARTY.
MULLIN.
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE WEBER.
SO THAT WILL BE ON CALL AND UP
FOR YOUR NEXT BILL.
LOOKS LIKE YOU HAVE A CHOICE A
TO. I'LL GO WITH.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS AND ALL
BUT ONE STATEWIDE ELECTION SINCE
TWO THOUSAND NINE A MAJORITY OF
CALIFORNIA VOTES.
HAVE BEEN CAST ON VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS
AND THE ROLE THAT THE POSTAL
SERVICEPLAYS IN OUR STATES
ELECTIONS WILL CONTINUE TO
INCREASE AS COUNTIES ADOPT THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS CHOICE ACT.
UNDER THAT LAW WHICH IS BEING
IMPLEMENTED FOR THE FIRST TIME
IN FIVE COUNTIES THIS YEAR.
EVERY VOTER IN A PARTICIPATING
COUNTY WILL AUTOMATICALLY
RECEIVE A BALLOT IN THE MAIL
WHETHER THEY REQUESTED ONE OR
NOT.
CALIFORNIA ALREADY REQUIRES
COUNTIES HAVE A FREE ACCESS
SYSTEM.
THAT ALLOWS A VOTE BY MAIL VOTER
TO DETERMINE IF HIS OR HER
BALLOT WAS RECEIVED BY THE
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL AND IF IT WAS
COUNTY.
THOSE SYSTEMS ARE IMPORTANT IN
HELPING MAINTAIN VOTERS
CONFIDENCE THAT THE BALLOTS ARE
COUNTED.
BUT OTHER JURISDICTIONS HAVE
ADOPTED MORE EXTENSIVE VOTE BY
MAIL TRACKING THE NOTIFICATION
SYSTEMS THAT CAN HELP IMPROVE
VOTER PARTICIPATION AND REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS THAT ARE INVALIDATED.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN REQUIRES
THE SECRETARY OF STATE TO
DEVELOP A SYSTEM FOR USE BY
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS THAT
ALLOWS A VOTER TO RECEIVE TEXT
OR EMAIL NOTIFICATIONS ABOUT THE
STATUS OF HIS OR HER VOTE. BY
MAIL BALLOT AS IT MOVES THROUGH
THE POSTAL SYSTEM AND AS IT IS
PROCESS BY THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL.
NOT ONLY WILL THE SYSTEM GIVE
VOTERS GREATER PEACE OF MIND
WHEN CASTING ABOUT BY MAIL. BUT
IT WILL ALSO HELP ELECTIONS
OFFICIALS TAKE STEPS TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER. OF VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOTS THAT ARE UNABLE TO BE
COUNTED.
ELECTIONS OFFICIALS WILL BE ABLE
TO QUICKLY CONTACT VOTERS WHOSE
BALLOTS A RETURNED AS
UNDELIVERABLE.
AND IF A VOTER FORGETS TO SIGN
THE VOTE BY MAIL BALLOT ENVELOPE
OR THE SIGNATURE ON THE ENVELOPE
DOESN'T MATCH THE ONE ON FILE
FOR THAT VOTER. THE ELECTIONS
OFFICIAL CAN USE THE SYSTEM TO
NOTIFY THE VOTER OF STEPS THAT
HERE SHE CAN TAKE TO HAVE THAT
BALLOT COUNTED.
AB TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN IS
SUPPORTED BY SECRETARY OF STATE
OUT EXPEDIA AND THEY SEE ALL YOU
AMONG OTHERS AND HAS NO
OPPOSITION I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
AND WITH ME. TODAY IS ROLL ROLL
MISIA'S UP FROM THE AMERICAN
CIVIL LIBERTIES UNION OF
CALIFORNIA CENTER FOR ADVOCACY
AND POLICY. AND MY OLD FRIEND
AND DEAR FRIEND TIFFANY BOX.
PLEASE PROCEED.
AT.
KAREN MEMBERS AROMASEAL SOME OF
OF A CITY OF CALIFORNIA WHERE
IT'S FOR THE BILL WE.
FOR THE REASONS THE AUTHOR SAID
WE.
AND WE AGREE THAT'S IMPORTANT
PROVIDE.
I HAVE VOTERS THAT PEACE OF MIND
THAT THE VOTERS COUNTED AND
PROVIDE THAT TRANSPARENCY WE
ALSO THINK IT'S IMPORTANT IN
THESE CASES WHERE THERE MAY BE A
PROBLEM WITH THE VOTE BY MAIL.
AND TO NOTIFY THE VOTER AND GIVE
THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO FIX
SOMETHING IF THERE IS AN ISSUE.
EFFECT.
BOB.
IT'S ALL YOURS CURRENTLY
INVOLVED IN LITIGATION OVER.
NOTICE IN THE ABILITY TO CARE
WHEN THERE'S A PROBLEM WITH A
SIGNATURE MATCHING.
I'M LOOK AT.
AB SUPERIOR COURT AND SENATE
CISCO RULED THAT ITS IMPACT
UNCONSTITUTIONAL NOT TO PROVIDE
VOTERS NOTICE AND OPPORTUNITY
CARE. I THINK THIS WOULD THIS
BILL WOULD GIVE AB COUNTIES THAT
TYPE OF SYSTEM THEY NEED. TO TO
NOTIFY VOTERS IT WOULD HELP AND
WE TAKE AN IMPORTANT SEPTIC
YOU SOLVING THAT. AS I THINK
IT'S WORTH NOTING IN IN THE DATA
WE.
I WE LOOKED AT REGARDING THE
SIGNATURE MATCH CASES.
THE.
THE VOTERS AFFECTED WERE
DISPROPORTIONATELY LATINO ASIAN
AMERICAN NATURALIZED CITIZENS
AND YOUNG VOTERS.
I'M FOR STRONG IT'S PART THE
SPELL WE THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
STEP TO NOTIFYING VOTERS IN
MAKING SURE THEY HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FIX ANY PROBLEMS
OF THE VOTES. AND GIVING VOTERS
A PIECE MIGHT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT BAKER
IN FAVOR.
TIFFANY MOCKUP ME HALF THE
SECRETARY STATE HOW EXPEDIA IN
SUPPORT OF THE.
THANK YOU BY ANY OTHERS ARE
WILLING TO.
OR WISHING TO WHY ADD THEIR
SUPPORT ON.
SEEING NONE ANY IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OUR. OR COMMENTS BY
THE COMMITTEE.
ALL AYE AYES AYE SECOND FOR
CONSIDERATION UP BUT I DO HAVE A
CONCERN THAT I DO WANT TO ASK
ABOUT.
LOTT MISTER CHAIR AT TWO YEARS
AGO A GOVERNOR BROWN VETOED A
SIMILAR BILL THAT WOULD REQUIRE
COUNTY ELECTIONS OFFICIALS TO
NOTIFY THEIR.
VOTERS IF THEY'RE VOTE BY MAIL
BALLOT WAS NOT COUNTED
TO PROVIDE THE REASONS WHY THE
BALLOT WAS NOT COUNTED.
THE GOVERNOR'S VETO MESSAGE I
STATED THAT THIS BILL IS
UNNECESSARY.
CURRENTLY LAW REQUIRES A COUNTY
ELECTIONS OFFICIAL TO ESTABLISH
OF FREE ACCESS SYSTEM. THAT
ALLOWS A VOTE BY MAIL VOTER TO
LEARN WHETHER HIS OR HER BALLOT
DISCOUNTED AND IF NOT THE REASON
WHY THE BALLOT WAS NOT COUNTD.
I BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
SUFFICIENT.
THE VOTER SAID IN HIS HAVE VETO
MESSAGE.
SO.
.
WITH THAT IF YOU CAN ARTICULATE.
REASONS WHY YOU THINK THAT THIS
MAIL BILL MAY BE DIFFERENT OR
MAKE THOSE ARGUMENTS ON WHY THE
GOVERNOR SHOULD RECONSIDER SURE
I'M NOT I THINK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION AT YOUR HARPER I'M NOT
INTIMATELY FAMILIAR WITH WITH
THE PRIOR BILL THAT WAS VETOED.
BUT THIS IT COULD CREATE EATEN
UTILIZES TECHNOLOGY TO EASILY
PUT OUT INFORMATION TO VOTERS TO
GIVE THEM AN UPDATE ON THE
STATUS OF THEIR BILL AS IT MOVES
ALONG IN THE PROCESS.
SO.
YOU KNOW THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S BEEN TRIED IN DENVER.
AND AND HAS BEEN PROVEN TO BE
SUCCESSFUL AND.
WERE ALL VERY BUSY.
AND ARE VOTERS.
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARE ARE.
BUSIER THAN WE ARE.
TRYING TO ESPECIALLY IN MY
DISTRICT MAKE ENOUGH MONEY TO
STAY THERE.
RAISE A FAMILY WORK.
MAYBE HAVE A HOBBY OR TWO AND
SO MOST OF THEM AFTER THEY VOTE.
ASSUME THEY VOTED.
AND THEY'RE NOT GOING ON TO A
WEBSITE TO CHECK WHETHER OR NOT
THERE BALLOT GOT COUNTY AND MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THE CURRENT
SYSTEM DOESN'T TELL THEM IF IT
WASN'T COUNTED IT JUST GIVES
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DETERMINE WHETHER OR NOT. IT WAS
COUNTY AND WE SHOULDN'T EXPECT
FROM OUR VOTERS THAT THEY HAVE
TO PROACTIVELY GO ONTO A WEBSITE
TO FIND OUT WHETHER OR NOT
THEY'RE BOTH ARE COUNTED WE E.
AS THE STATE. SHOULD PROVIDE
THEM WITH THE DATA THAT IF IT
WASN'T COUNTED Y. NOT.
AND AND WHAT CAN THEY DO TO
REMEDY THE SITUATION THIS IS.
A SYSTEM A A.
NOT VERY EXPENSIVE SYSTEM THAT
GIVES OUR VOTERS INFORMATION.
RATHER THAN EXPECTING THAT
THEY'RE CONSTANTLY TRACKING THE
BALLOT THEY SHOULD HAVE THE
CONFIDENCE IN THE SYSTEM THAT
ONCE THEY SUBMIT THE BALLOT IT'S
IT'S GOOD. IF IT IS AND I THINK
WE AS A STATE GIVEN THE THE
NOMINAL COST OF THE PROGRAM.
AND AND THE BENEFIT THAT IT
PROVIDES.
SHOULD PROVIDE THEM WITH THAT
INFORMATION IN IN THIS SEEMS
LIKE A GOOD WAY TO DO IT BALLOT
MY MY WITNESSES THAT CAN I WOULD
JUST ADD ON SO. THE CORDON
CHAIRMAN JUST GO.
LOOK AT THIS AND SAID THAT'S NOT
GOOD ENOUGH THAT DUE PROCESS
REQUIRES AFFIRMATIVE NOTICE.
WHEN WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT THAT THE
GOVERNMENT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
NOTIFY. VOTERS IT'S NOT ENOUGH
TO SAY THERE'S A PLACE TO GO
LOOK AT.
THANK YOU AND THE BILL WAS
ALREADY YOU HAD ALREADY MOVED
THE BILL AND I HAD A RE-ATTEMPT.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER. QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I SEEING NONE OF WHICH YOU LIKE.
ANY ADDITIONAL COMMENTS TO
CLOSE ORDER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
A VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU AND.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND THEN MOTION IS TO PASS AND
RE REFER TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE BERMAN AYE AYE BERMAN
AYE HARPER.
HARPER NO CALDERON. CALDERON AYE
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
STEINORTH I STEINORTH AYE WEBER.
THAT BILL IS OUT FOR LUNCH AYE
LETS HER GO AHEAD AND PROCEED IT
LOOKS LIKE THE ONLY REMAINING
BILL IS. ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE NINETY TWO MISTER CHAIRMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS EVERY TEN YEARS THE
UNITED STATES CENSUS BUREAU
CONDUCTS A SURVEY OF EVERYONE
LIVING IN THE COUNTRY.
CENSUS DATAIS USED TO DETERMINE
POLITICAL REPRESENTATION
INCLUDING HOW MANY SEATS EACH
STATE HAS IN THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES AND DISTRIBUTE
OVER SIX HUNDRED SEVENTY FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING.
STATE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FOR
HEALTHCARE EDUCATION
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
IMPORTANT SERVICES.
UNFORTUNATELY MANY CHALLENGES
THREATEN A COMPLETE AND ACCURATE
COUNT OF CALIFORNIANS IN THE
CENSUS.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO TEN OF THE
NATION'S FIFTY HARDEST ACCOUNT
COUNTIES WHICH ARE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THE SELF RESPONSE RATE TO
THE CENSUS. QUESTIONNAIRE HAS
HISTORICALLY BEEN LOW.
FURTHERMORE THE UNITED STATES
CENSUS BUREAU LACKS A PERMANENT
DIRECTOR AND HAS HAD TO CANCEL
KEY PREPARATIONS.
INCLUDING TESTING A NEW AND
UNUSED INTERNET BASED
METHODOLOGY FOR CENSUS RESPONSE.
AS A RESULT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABILITY OFFICE
HAS DEEMED THE CENSUS AND AT
RISK PROGRAM.
IN RECOGNITION OF CALIFORNIA'S
NEED TO PROMOTE THE CENSUS
GOVERNOR BROWN INCLUDED FORTY
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS FOR
CENSUS OUR REGION IS FISCAL YEAR
TWENTY EIGHTEEN TWENTY NINETEEN
BUDGET.
ADDITIONALLY BOTH THE ASSEMBLY
AND THE SENATE HAVE ESTABLISHED
NEW SELECT COMMITTEES NEW
BIPARTISAN SELECT COMMITTEES
TASK WITH SENSES ARE RICH AND
CONVENING INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ACROSS THE STATE.
AB TWENTY NINE FIFTY TWO IS
CONSISTENT WITH THESE EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE AWARENESS AND
PARTICIPATION IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS.
AB TWENTY NINE FIVE.
THANK YOU.
A BETWEEN AT FIFTY TWO IS
CONSISTENT WITH THESE EFFORTS TO
PROMOTE AWARENESS OF
PARTICIPATION IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY CENSUS. SPECIFICALLY THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE THE SECRETARY
OF STATE TO INCLUDE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE TWENTY TWENTY CENSUS
ON THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
WEBSITE AND IN PUBLIC ELECTION
MATERIALS PRODUCED. BY THE
SECRETARY OF STATE SUCH AS THE
STATE VOTER INFORMATION GUIDE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE ON A
BETWEEN FIVE NINETY TWO AND WITH
ME IS TIFFANY MARK.
SPEAKING OF FAVOR.
AT NEW MARKET.
I BEHALF OF THE SECRETARY OF
STATE ALEX PADILLA IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD.
PATIENTS APART.
THANK YOU ANY OTHERS ARE
SPEAKING IN FAVOR.
SEEING NONE I ANYONE WISHING TO
SPEAK AGAINST THE BILL.
ANY COMMENTS QUESTIONS UP FROM
THE OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
I'LL JUST TAKE EXPRESS THAT UP.
I'LL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL AND.
IN MY HOPE IS THAT THE.
OUTREACH EFFORTS ARE A BROAD
BASED IN THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
AYE BECAUSE I THINK IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR A CALIFORNIANS I
TO BE COUNTED AYE IN THE U. S.
CENSUS.
BUT OF COURSE I WANT THOSE
EFFORTS TO BE APPLIED IN EVERY
CORNER OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
AND WITH THAT WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE MISTER JUST RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH UP PLEASE UP
PROCEED WITH THE.
CULTURAL. THE MOTIONS TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE BERMAN
HIGH BERMAN AYE HARPER AYE.
HARPER AYE CALDERON. CALDERON HI
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE WEBER.
MR BELDA THOUGHT MISTER CHAIR
THAT THE BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO.
THING AND I THINK THAT CONCLUDES
YOUR YOUR CALENDAR OF PILL
.
YOUR
SO WE HAVE A COUPLE OF BILLS ON
CALL. MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE LET
THE CALL ON THE BILLS AND IT
MEMBERS TO. DEVOTE.
OKAY.
STARTING WITH AB TWENTY FIFTY
FIVE.
ITEM NUMBER TWO.
CALDERON.
CALDERON IS NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE STEINORTH.
STEINORTH NOT VOTING.
SO THAT'S OUT ON A FOUR ZERO
VOTE.
NEXT IS AYE NUMBER TEN AB
TWENTY SIXTY.
AB TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE OF
SECRETARY PLEASE CULTURAL.
CALDERON.
TWENTY SIX EIGHTY NINE I'D.
CALDERON AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MULLIN. AYE MULLIN AYE
STEINORTH.
STEINORTH AYE.
SO THAT'S OUT ON A SIX ZERO VOTE
NEXT UP ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB
TWENTY ONE TWENTY THREE THE
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TO ONE AND
THE CHAIR RECOMMENDATION IS AN
AYE VOTE.
CALDERON. CALDERON AYE MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
STEINORTH STEINORTH AYE.
THAT'S OUT ON THE SIX TWO ONE
VOTE.
THE NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
TWENTY FIVE.
TWELVE.
THAT IS A ONE TO ONE VOTE IN
THE CHAIR RECOMMENDATION IS A NO
VOTE.
CALDERON.
CALDERON NO MCCARTY MCCARTY NOW
MULLIN. MULLIN NOW STEINORTH.
STEINORTH I WEBER NAY WEBER NO.
THAT BILL FAILS ON A TWO TO FIVE
VOTE.
BECAUSE THE NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY.
AND THAT IS CURRENTLY A TWO TO
ZERO VOTE IN THE CHAIR
RECOMMENDATION IS A YES VOTE.
CALDERON.
CALDERON AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
STEINORTH. STEINORTH AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
THAT'S OUT ON A SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
THE NEXT IS ITEM NUMBER.
IS IT SEVEN. SEVEN.
AB TWENTY THREE CERTAIN THAT HE
BEAT TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FIVE
CURRENTLY A THREE ZERO VOTE AND
THAT YOUR RECOMMENDATION IS AN
AYE VOTE.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE STEINORTH STEINORTH
AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
IT'S OUT ON A SEVEN ZERO VOTE.
AND THE NEXUS AB THIRTY SEVENTY
FIVE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE.
AND THAT HAS A THAT'S A THREE TO
ZERO VOTE AND IT'S THE CHAIRS
BILL.
SO THE RECOMMENDATION IS AYE.
YEAH.
THAT IT WAS INTUITIVE AS TO WHAT
THAT.
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE A WEBER.
WEBER I.
I DESERVE THAT.
THAT'S AT ON A SIX ZERO VOTE.
.
GREAT SO.
YES I WILL NOT GO BACK FOR THE
REMAINING BILLS TO GIVE CHAIR
AFTER YOU MEMBERS AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT ON.
I.
IN THE FIRST IS GONNA BE
CONSENT.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
THAT'S A NEED TWENTY NINETY FIVE
AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I STEINORTH AYE STEINORTH
AYE.
ON ITEM FIVE ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TWO EIGHTEEN FIVE BERMAN
MR MULLIN.
MULLIN I WEBER. WEBER AYE EDIT
AND UPDATE FOR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
AYE AYE NUMBER ONE CHOI WAS
PULLED BEFORE COMMITTEE.
I AM ITEM SIX ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY TO FORTY FIVE BY THE
CHAIR AND MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN. MULLIN AYE
WEBER. WEBER AYE.
ON THIS ITEM ITEM NINE ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY FIVE NINETY TWO BY
THE CHAIR MISTER MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
AND THAT'S IT.
SO WITH THAT THE MEETING IS
ADJOURNED THANK YOU COLLEAGUES